931 we will start the public hearing on
HB 93.
oops yes and first thing we need to do
public for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
okay so with that
like to start open public hearing on HB
93 authorizing municipalities to reduce
speed limits seasonally
and the chair like to recognize the
representative uh Abel who is uh the
sponsor of the bill
very much Mr chairman and committee
members my name is Karen Ebel I'm here
uh representing Merrimack District 7
which is uh New London and Newbury
so the bill that you have before you
is actually an attempt to give towns
parallel authority to the authority that
the state has under our statutes and
that is that a town should be authorized
seasonally to reduce the speed limit
below 25 to 20 miles an hour either at
its own
under its own volition or upon Petition
of um of folks that live along a road
that they consider has safety issues and
they would like to reduce the speed
limit
um
the petition
um procedure would be that uh 10
residents could petition a town to
consider the reduction of the speed
limit from 25 to 20 and then the town in
consultation with the petitioners
um
can decide whether they think that
that's a reasonable and appropriate
thing to do and then they would have to
write to the petitioners to to let them
know what their decision is the
situation came up in my district in
particular we have many water bodies in
our district as many of you do and you
know that along those water bodies the
engineers and their wisdom in the old
days decided to put Lakes right along
and put roads right along Lake Shores
many of those roads are narrow
Meandering and they have cottages on one
side many of the roads are through roads
but they're also very very popular for
pedestrians for bike riders for runners
for dog walkers and in the summer in
particular they can get really congested
and
um
towns need quite a few Tools in their
toolbox to try to figure out how to
reduce the speed and increase the safety
on these roads and as we were discussing
this in our town we could do signage we
could do any number of things but when
the discussion arose that maybe we could
reduce the speed limit for 20 from 25
miles an hour to 20 we found out that
even though the state can do this we
towns cannot so it was brought to my
attention actually our town had reached
out to dot at that point and it was
brought to my attention by Bill Lambert
who was at the D.O.T and he suggested to
me and our Town Administrator that if we
were interested in trying to rectify
this issue this was the sort of Bill
that had to be introduced used to bring
it before the transportation committee
and he helped me with the language
Mr Lambert is traveling today he can't
be here but a representative from dot is
here and she will provide you with a
letter from from Dot
I just wanted to speak a little bit
about the authority that the state has
many of you may know Senator Nancy
Stiles worked for quite a while on this
issue in Hampton and in Hampton there's
a state road that goes along the beach
and there was a lot of interest in the
town of Hampton as I understand it to be
able to reduce the speed limit and in
that case the state can consider the
reduction of the speed limit seasonally
upon Petition of the governing
municipality so what I did was with the
assistance of dot I basically paralleled
my bill to that the only difference is I
didn't want a town to have to wait until
there was a petition to make this
decision I wanted the town to be able to
do it itself if it wanted to so the only
other thing I would add is that this
would be at no cost to the state any
signage would have to be borne by the
town but it would have to be approved by
dot
um
and with that I'll I'd be happy to take
any questions to the extent my expertise
in these matters allow
thank you thank you very much any
questions from the committee
thanks
um thank you Mr chair
would this only be on town or city-owned
roads through going through the
municipality yes
municipally owned roads and uh class
five I believe
um right I mean it's an interesting
situation that in some cases the roads
that are could be affected like along a
lake part of them may be owned by the
town and part of them may be owned by
the state and so there's a petition
process to reduce the speed limit for
the state but there was really nothing
for the town so this would enable some
homogeneous speed
limits along a lake where that occurs
follow-up
thank you and when you say seasonal help
me with that term please you know in my
mind in New Hampshire I mean it was in
our area it's summer that's when people
are I mean it could be I don't know in
Colebrook they want to do it in the
winter time but for for me it would be
summer I didn't Define seasonal
um I think that would be up to whoever
was requesting the the permission but
the important part is it's just like it
is for the state it's a four-month um
window and you can only have one four
month window per 12 month period so it's
not an across the board authority to
reduce it to 20 miles an hour which
again tracks what is happening at the
state level thank you
any other questions representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
is there any concern on your part or was
there consideration for those roads that
that may switch back and forth I can
think of one in Meredith that switches
back and forth between two towns twice
within a a very short
period of time and it would seem to me
there would need to have to be some
coordination between towns or you would
be accelerating and decelerating quickly
in order to maintain the the correct
speed was that was that part of this at
all uh representative Hill it's a very
good question I didn't I thought about
the about the state Town dichotomy I
have to be honest I didn't
think that much about the town Town
dichotomy but I would think any town in
deciding whether or not it would want to
do this
one of the considerations should be that
they consult with neighboring towns if
their decision affects them
I don't think that it should be
confusing for
the drivers I mean you'll want
I guess the only other thing I'd say
though is there are many situations in
which there are speed limit changes from
50 to 35 when you go through a town so
representative Rambo thank you Mr chair
uh thank you for taking my question I
just want to be clear that once the
process the petition process goes
through if there's a speed limit change
it's the four months that's set and then
that would stay that way going forward
it's not a temporary process it's not
they wouldn't revisit it after you know
the season that sort of this would be a
going forward I mean in my
in my mind it would be Revisited
huh okay uh but that doesn't mean that
that's 100 correct I mean we could see
what the uh What DOT says I mean as I
wrote this
I would think it would be a recurring
thing you know that the towns could uh
could reassess it I guess the other
thing I would say is if it was
originally initiated through a petition
process then the town could do it at its
own you know volition in the future
okay thank you
representative sellers Mr chair actually
I have like five or six questions should
I take them one at a time let's start
with the first one thank you all right
I'm going to work a little backwards
then uh regarding connecting towns with
speed limits that you that you didn't
think of all right that's okay
do they have to get 10 petitioners at
that point
I think any the way this is written any
town
would be should be uh the decider as to
whether or not it's going to reduce the
speed limit on its own Town Road so yes
I would think the process would be the
same for an adjoining town
next question second question thank you
since there's uh 10 petitioners would
they once they petition the town would
they have to have a hearing at all so
the other towns people know that this is
going on so um I think an important part
of the bill the way we wrote it was that
the
um the town would have to consult with
the petitioners and that I I just can't
imagine that that wouldn't be done in
the context of a selectman's meeting
okay
next we'll give you one more all right
thank you
I'm going to combine them no I won't the
uh do you know if there's been any
has there been any stats or accidents
like that that the reason for just
lowering the lowering the speed
well I don't
I don't personally have statistics I
think that might be something that you
could discuss with uh with DOT what I do
know anecdotally is if people slow down
when there's uh pedestrians and dogs uh
walking on the road that can only help
the safety situation I mean I I think
we've all observed how these roads
Meander along lakes and how popular they
are for Walkers and you have to reduce
actually I have a question in terms of
some of these rows that have a speed
limit sign already and they decide to
reduce it
how is handling I guess how is the
signage handled do they cover up the
initial sign and there's a temporary
um well what I've observed in my town is
that they put up a a sign that sort of
flashes and it would probably say
seasonal speed limit reduction 25 miles
or 20 miles per hour
um there may be people with more
expertise on that than what I have but
um I think where there's a will there's
a way
representative Coker thank you Mr
chairman um so with this um is there any
way for the D.O.T to kind of once this
petition makes it to the dot is there
any way for the dot to kind of look at
it and and for whatever reason rejected
or or if there's a compelling reason to
do so just to clarify the petition is
actually uh something that would be
presented to the municipality and since
it's a Town Road it would be the
municipalities decision and
the place where dot would become
involved would be the design and
approval of the signage okay so it'd be
a hundred percent of the towns yes I
mean because they're town roads Okay so
any other further questions from the
committee
representative Sykes yeah
a question of the chair actually
um
will we be hearing from the D.O.T yes
I'll hold my question for them thank you
Mr chair could I add one thing I just
want to my focus has been Lakeside roads
because that's our personal experience I
just want I mean in your expertise I
just want to point out that this is an
across the board
bill it doesn't just apply to Lakes okay
thank you not seeing any further
chair like to recognize Kimberly
hollabist
who's requesting two minutes who
supports the bill
did I get your name correct
good morning yes it's Kim Hall Quest
sorry I'm a little I was holding on to
my card it's a little messy uh good
morning thank you Mr chair and members
of the committee I'm here to speak in
favor uh in support of this bill
representative Ebel was very helpful in
bringing this to your attention
in New London we have as representative
Ebel described Lake roads small windy
roads where the population of the summer
residents balloons starting in Memorial
weekend on and we have people that you
may have heard other in other areas
speed limit issues around the state and
around the country it's a it's a big
issue and
the worry here in our some of our town
roads is that we the Selectmen are not
able to lower the speed limits to what
they feel would be a safe limit you'll
hear from some residents of one of the
roads in in New London and they will
describe some dangerous situations so
when we looked into the law and found
that the selectman could not lower it to
20 miles an hour the thought was that
there should be a law to allow Selectmen
to do that
to the questions of public hearings and
things like that I think most towns if
even if it wasn't in the law would hold
public hearings because the idea is that
we really want people to know about the
change in New London we would put new
speed limit signs up the regulation
speed limit and we would probably also
put something on the speed limit post to
point out that these are different
representative evil also suggest we do
have electronic signs that would allow
the new speed limit to be readily known
the idea is that we really want people
to do the speed limit if we had people
if everybody observed the speed limit we
wouldn't have these issues but
unfortunately the the numbers of people
that are
speeding are up so we feel a New London
that this would help increase the safety
of our residents and our visitors to the
to the town and that's what we're
looking to do
thank you any questions from the
committee
not seeing any thank you thank you for
chair would like to recognize natch
graze
who is from the nhma did I get that
correct
thank you yes and requesting two minutes
who's who's in support of the Bill thank
you nature Grace for the municipal
Association we do support this bill
um I don't have much to add here I just
want to emphasize this isn't only for
Lakeside communities it might apply to
uh communities that have uh agriculture
during harvest season
um and see a lot of parking or walking
along roads there hiking skiing snow
shoeing Etc and there's certainly plenty
of things we do outside here in New
Hampshire
um just to reiterate a question that
that came earlier
um this would be for only municipally
owned roads which are class four five
and six roads
um and it's the way we read it um it's
seasonal
um and it would be reoccurring but there
would be that ability to reassess it to
make sure that this was an appropriate
appropriately targeted towards the
actual use of the road that's really the
the intent here
um as far as the signage question goes
um municipalities are required of course
to use the uniform manual on traffic
control devices
um and I assume based on the fact that
uh dot uses that as well and would be
approving any sort of signage that would
that would go up that uh there would be
clear coordination there so there would
not be any confusion about uh what roads
are are what the speed limit is On Any
Given Road I'm happy to take any
questions that the committee may have
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
representative Sinclair
thank you Mr chair thanks um
so you represent the municipalities
Statewide I do thank you so my question
is
do they not now and if they have an area
where there's a lot of pedestrian
activity put signs up just to warn
people of that no matter what the speed
limit is
or can they not do that now
I'm not an expert at uh traffic control
devices so I defer to dot on that one I
believe I mean just driving around I've
seen uh types of signs like that but I I
don't know what's allowed and what's not
allowed so I defer to dot on that one
thank you
and we have someone from the D.O.T who
will be testifying shortly any other
questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
chair I'd like to recognize David
Damaris
um requesting two minutes
he's in support of the bill and he's
here we are thank you good morning again
and thank you for the opportunity to to
speak today my name is David Demers and
I live at 586 bunker Road in New London
uh I've spoken on road speed and safety
on behalf of our neighbors in the town
before our town selectman and also
assisted in fundraising and approval for
permanent feedback signs uh on our road
um as as Kim and Karen had mentioned our
road is probably
perhaps situationally a good example of
why we need this bill
bunkers erode that follows the perimeter
of Pleasant Lake along one side
and it's a very old road we've lived on
it for nearly 30 years
and and the original Road itself was
constructed as Kim had mentioned between
cottages and has a very very narrow
soft shoulder that leads right down into
the lake
uh it is an old road as many Lake areas
have and it's highly used for
multi-purpose on
I use this
for walkers for runners for bikers and
travelers who seek the beauty of
Lakeside views in the 30 years that
we've lived there the number of people
that are using that the lake in that way
using that road has risen dramatically
and but we also have commuters who
travel the same road as a shortcut to
town and to in into Route 1 route 89.
now while the road is currently set at
25 miles an hour and to your question
about adding signs the town has been
very good about adding signs uh warning
people about the curves and about the
Walkers and uh and and they have been
keeping uh some of those feedback signs
uh active but they are rotated up till
now in various areas
we personally observed and the data
would show that people try to stay in in
that speed limit but the grades on the
hill coming into that and once you get
into the curves there's not enough
visibility
for drivers or for Walkers to see
oncoming traffic and because of the the
soft shoulders in high periods of use
like the spring and summer
um drivers who are going too quick can't
uh can't actually maneuver around those
people that are there I as an example
and to the question about whether or not
there are any any observations about
driver safety or I'm sorry about uh
drivers losing control uh we have
personally witnessed a driver losing
control of his car at our property one
of our our Lots there because he was
driving too quick
it was a young driver he was likely
distracted coming through and he
careened off the road hitting a tree on
our property uh fortunately he was
guided down heading to the to the water
hitting a rock before he narrowly missed
rolling over and into the into the lake
but that location where he went off on
Bunker is precisely where my
grandchildren stand while they wait to
cross the road from the water in the
summertime
now
he was on a curve area coming through
and and again the speed that one goes
has to be linked to the curves
because if you if you're in those curves
and you don't have visibility you're not
able to break in time and even though
the speed limit is 25 people exceed that
speed limit
we've also seen situations where members
of our family friends and neighbors have
had their safety compromised by drivers
traveling too fast to adjust their speed
when they come upon Walkers and Runners
with narrow options because of those
soft shoulders steep embankments as that
young driver discovered and blind curves
the bill will allow the town to address
this kind of safety risk
growing vehicle and multi-purpose use on
the lake roads like ours warrants this
important tool for our town and for
others that have popular multi-purpose
usage
and particularly where Road designs were
you know were established in the 1900s
and we it's otherwise not feasible for
us to take uh and put any kind of
changes to the direction of the road
because of the Cottages that are on the
other side
uh your vote will in our mind and our
personal experience save lives
it'll share the beauty of our special
areas on Pleasant Lake where people now
are hesitant to go down there for fear
that they they or their grandchildren
will have a problem similar to the one I
I expressed to you
I hope you respond to this growing
concern and allow the municipalities
like ours to make the right call on
roads that need seasonal speed
reductions local decisions have to be
made at that level
thank you
thank you so much any questions from the
committee representative Sinclair
thank you and thank you thank you in
Laconia when we've had problems you know
people complaining about speed the
police department has put up these boxes
that register the speed of all of
vehicles so they have that that
information yes has that been done in
your town I'm glad you asked that
question thank you for it in fact uh New
London has rotational placement of those
feedback signs uh in our case on our
situational requirement we wanted to
have those signs there permanently and
we raised the money in I'm sorry these
aren't signs these are boxes that are up
that that's right that's what I'm
discussing but it's not a sign it's a
box that gathers information yeah we
raised uh in our in our neighborhood for
this road we raised over seven thousand
dollars to to buy two of those uh
feedback I think they call them feedback
signs and
um and you know it wasn't that the town
wasn't paying attention to this they do
rotate those around and they are useful
but our desire was to have a permanent
set particularly in the Narrows area of
our of our road where they the greatest
risk is and those signs will be put in
place the dedicated signs uh this spring
and we hope to use the the speed limit
along the new speed adjustment at 20 in
conjunction with those new signs
follow up thank you so you have no data
now that shows that what the what kind
of speed people are doing other than
we do the the town has placed those
signs
uh periodically in the Narrows area so
we have you know we have the average
speeds and we have the uh upper upper
and the upper side variation is what
we're worried about it isn't that
drivers themselves
try to beat that speed it is a situation
where you get into those curves and you
don't have enough stopping distance to
get to get to be safe there so perhaps
Kim can give you the data better than I
can but
but the um the beauty of those signs
those feedback signs is that they
capture that data
and for us that's one of the reasons why
we spent seven thousand neighbors spent
over seven thousand dollars to put two
of them in there
so that we can monitor when the that
variability occurs particularly at the
okay thank you
any other questions from the committee
chair now like to recognize Doug Baxter
who supports the bill requesting five
minutes and also representing
representing New London residents
welcome
good morning thank you all for this
opportunity to speak
um before I do speak just to address
representative Sinclair's question New
London does have the Black Box
um that's sort of strapped onto a
telephone pole and does record the data
I do not have any of the results but it
was the old 80 20 rule 80 of the people
are following the speed limit more so
more or less it's at 20 percent that we
found was of the extremes
um I David addressed the bunker Road
situation I am a property owner on
Bunker Road and my family we're all
bikers and Walkers and we've had more
than one uh avoidance maneuver uh
because of the examples that David used
but I also wanted to speak to
um Elkins Road which is coming down into
the south end of the lake where our town
beach is
um our post office
um our boat launch and the town Dam
which is a popular hangout area and I'm
also the the coordinator for the lake
house for for our Lake and have spent a
fair amount of time at the boat launch
and get reports from our Lake host of
the number of near-misses we've had at
the boat launches unfortunately there's
not a long approach to the boat launch
so anyone launching a boat there is in
the middle of the road backing in or
pulling out and so we do have a
dangerous situation there and it's also
another example where we have a deep
grade coming down into it so it's just
gravity adds to the situation so
um I I my observations have been even
with our 25 mile per hour speed limits I
would guess and again this is just my
observation that people are going about
35 on average it's very easy to do I
find myself without paying attention you
can be going 35 before you know it so
I'm looking at this from an awareness
standpoint that in addition to all the
other steps we've taken with pedestrian
well-marked pedestrian Crossings with
signage and markings in the road
just a different it's another tool as
someone had said in the toolbox that it
will create an awareness that
something's different here and I hope
that it would help slow people down to
maybe the speed limit or close to it
I think we were all very guilty of
Leaning heavily on our Police Department
in the past
um to their their job to fix this I
realize now that I think Society has
expanded the envelope of what is
acceptable speeding I mean just driving
down 89 today I was going 71 and I was
the slowest car in the road I think but
uh I I speak in favor of this bill
because I think it was significantly
help our cause and other lakes and areas
in the state thank you
thank you any questions from the
committee
Cheryl now like to recognize Kathleen
mulhaney hampson if I said it right from
the New Hampshire D.O.T requesting two
minutes
foreign thank you Mr chair members of
the committee Kathy Mulcahy hampson I am
the legislative liaison for the
Department of Transportation and the
senior hearings examiner
um I am not the guru of speed limits or
signage our Guru Mr Bill Lambert the
administrator of the Bureau of traffic
is unfortunately unable to attend today
he did work on the language on this bill
with representative Ebel it would allow
the municipalities authority to post
lower speed limits that they deem
necessary or reasonable we've seen it
usually in Lake areas where there's a
lot of pedestrians and bicyclists
wanting to access the area for that
summer season that's the issue that
we're aware of
um
anecdotally I have recently read that
the state has jurisdiction of 10 of the
roads in New Hampshire so there's an
awful lot of Municipal roads at that
that figured um really was surprising to
me
um but there are a lot of Municipal
roads this bill would give authority to
the municipalities to
um set the speed limit lower
um for a season
I've passed out a letter of explanation
from Bill Lambert who as I said can't be
here today to testify and answer your
questions I don't know how the chair
would like to handle questions I can
take the questions for Mr Lambert and
have them get back to you or communicate
directly with Mr Lambert whatever works
best for the committee members that
would probably work best to get to you
and you can get them to Mr Lambert
so any questions from the committee
representative value
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question uh we had a bill like
this last term and uh Mr Lambert
testified that
um
speed limits weren't dependent on the
quality and condition of the road rather
than speed limits and without constant
enforcement science are really not
effective do you recommend any like
friction devices or anything that would
anything like that that towns could use
to slow down traffic to create kind of a
psychological calming effect on drivers
I think they use those speed limit
feedback signs but I'll have Mr Lambert
representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
does the dot or perhaps maybe someone
else can provide us if it exists any
actual crash data for these types of
circumstances
um yeah yeah I'm not sure if that would
be um
d-o-t-o-d-o-s would have those crash but
just to follow up follow up I'm I'm just
specifically about these types of
circumstances where uh seasonally
there's a heavier use of of the roads
I'm not looking for crashed out or every
single town on road that there might be
thank you
okay any further questions from the
committee
representative C
thank you Mr chairman
um the question I had is uh relates to
um the state route numbers
and whether the town would have any
authority over those if they pass
through the town because that's probably
the main traffic route through a town
as compared to just a strictly
town-owned Road
there are municipal con compacts
representative and I don't know how that
would be impacted by this but usually
within a municipal compact along a state
highway the municipality controls that
okay any further questions from the
committee representative Sinclair thank
you and thank you
um
do you know of any highways that are
controlled by this state where they
actually do this during
for seasonal operation
I believe there are some areas where
based on Senator Styles bill that she
filed several years ago along New
Hampshire 1A and 1B from Northampton to
Ryan Newcastle
um I think there were some speed
adjustments made seasonally
thank you
not seeing any thank you thank you
okay with that I do not have anybody
else uh written down to testify so this
will end the testimony for HB 98 93
next bill we'll be looking at is HB
okay be it uh 1010 I'd like to open up
the public hearing on HB 55 relative to
driver education
at this point the chair would like to
recognize
Mike Moffett
thank you Mr chair great to be back in
transportation
and I'll see you this afternoon as well
so for the record uh I'm representative
Mike Moffett of Merrimack District for
the
beautiful towns of Canterbury and
Loudoun so like most folks I once took a
driver red course I was 15 back in 1971
at droved in high school
and I don't I don't remember paying
anything with my family paying anything
I just recall signing up for it
along with many other students and
having classes after school
and scheduling Road time with the
instructor to include some some City
Driving in the big city of Berlin which
was a big city back then
so our instructor is a Catholic nun
named sister Anita
we called it The Flying Nun
um sometimes sister Anita would place a
golf ball in a tee inside the driver red
car and if the ball fell off the tee
that met the driver was not driving
smoothly and safely
now I don't know what Groveton High
School pays sister Anita
I'm sure it wasn't much but everyone who
wanted to take driver would get to take
it basically basically for free
and my dad spent a lot of time with me
as well uh riding with me around the
North Country in our
1966 red Rambler American
so I ended up getting 100 in the driver
at exam I got my license uh 1971 and
I've been driving for us over 50 years
um without even a speeding ticket knock
on wood kiss of death I know
so anyway HB 55 is a reprise of earlier
measures in this area seeking to allow
parents to teach their children how to
drive their youngsters had to drive and
part of the impetus here
involves the current High Cost of driver
education
and you'll hear more about that later
500 600 800 seems like a lot to some
folks especially is I didn't have to pay
sister a need or anything
and another issue involves weightless
and we hear that some waiting times last
six months eight months
and if somebody needs to wait almost a
year before they can get into a Drive
Away class that's a problem especially
if somebody's 16 17 if you've got to
wait six months to a year in some cases
they're just not taking driver red you
know waiting until they're 18.
so in knowing the driver education
yields better drivers it's a concern of
a lot of folks now you'll hear from
folks with experience in this area about
why this bill maybe isn't a good idea
it's been here before and that's to be
expected
uh in in The Drive Red folks there are
good folks who care about driver
education
now education is something I've devoted
much of my life to uh as a school board
I taught in public parochial military
schools College Community College
University I was on education committee
here for a couple of times so education
is part of my journey
and I have to harken back to the
scary testimony 20 years ago from the
education establishment opposing home
schooling
and it was a it was a battle as some of
you will remember to uh give
homeschooling a chance
which we finally did
and uh the results have been very very
impressive I was seriously parents take
their education of their youngsters in
The Homeschool community
teaching parents have skin in the game
so to speak
and they have every reason to want their
youngsters their kids to learn right and
to learn well the parents do
and I think many of us believe that
parents responsible for driver education
of their youngsters would go above and
beyond
expectations
and again if we allow parents to teach
their youngsters uh physics chemistry
biology you name it why not driver
education
and of course road tests and written
exams will still be part of the process
of course
to ensure that anyone who gets a
driver's license meets the the state's
standards and expectations whether they
take a course from a school or from a at
school or driver at Academy or from
their folks
so you'll hear about safety concerns
later and those are fair concerns about
the importance of safe drivers of course
we all want safe drivers
uh but who could possibly more be more
concerned about the safety of drivers
than the parents of the of the young
people who are going to be driving
uh
driver education statutes differ from
state to state Alabama Minnesota North
Dakota and others don't even require
State mandated driver education they
leave the curricular and the policies up
to the localities and to the parents
this apparently worked out well in those
States
Senator Lang and I had a very nice
meeting last week with some DMV folks
and some driver-red professionals uh
last Friday and I think we all left
there wiser as to the differing
perspectives on driver education
and a fair observation was made at that
meeting we had that some parents may not
may not be great teachers they may not
be the best role models
if they were bad drivers themselves
maybe they wouldn't be good teachers I
think that's a fair observation
understand that concern so
um
I think that this
type of measure could be improved by
adding some guard rails so to speak
um
this is the committee's bill now it's a
good bill
so the guardrails I speak of if you want
to work this a little bit
is to address the concerns of parents
who may be suspect Drive red teachers
which I think there'd be very few
uh to Simply add language that
to be a teaching a home schooler so to
speak for driver that you would need to
have a solid driving record I think that
would be an easy Amendment
in response to the meeting we had last
week with the driver red folks
so uh it's a good measure that hopefully
will safely move down the legislative
road to the Finish Line without too many
u-turns red lights or no passing Lanes
although hopefully the ought to pass
Lane is is one that this bill will find
so anyway thanks for your time and
attention and I know there's more
testimony to follow be happy to try to
answer any questions if if there are any
thank you so much any questions from the
committee
chair now like to recognize Michael
Doucette
from Precision Driving School and White
Mountains Community College
who opposes the bill and is asking for
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
uh I come here today with two hats as
you read off uh I am the owner of
Precision Driving School in Littleton
and uh my history I served 24 years with
the state police here in New Hampshire
19 of those years I was in the
instructor for driving for this Troopers
in law enforcement around New Hampshire
I did that in the last six years on the
job I was I ran the program when I left
the state police in 2004 the next 12
years I taught Special Forces folks uh
driving and being in New Hampshire and
in Florida
and when I gave up that position I had
parents asking me if I would consider
teaching driver education which I did go
through the process and and then I'll
have my own School
um I stand here from Precision Driving
School and say I oppose this bill uh I
is you're going to hear many folks
behind me give you some more reasons but
one of the reasons representative
Moffitt brought was you know the parents
we can teach physics and all these other
courses at home but there is no other
course that they're going to teach that
can save their lives than driver
education so on the other side of this
coin I'm here for as the program
coordinator for the driver education
instructor program
I took that over a year and a half ago
as the program coordinator and since
that time we've changed the way we get
instructors through the program it used
to be our school in Keene State would
have courses in the fall or courses in
the spring but people would have to wait
and it happened to me as a driving
school owner I would hire someone in
April and I would say okay the courses
start in August and we'll get you in
well between April and August the
instructor would say yeah I found
something else to do I'm not not gonna
not gonna go through those courses so
now I have a week left to get someone
into that program which is not going to
happen so we had a real problem with
getting instructors through and I've
changed the way the process is there's
three courses that a a potential
instructor has to take to get into
driver education introduction to Traffic
Safety classroom methods and in-vehicle
methods those three courses are called
the provisional courses I've changed it
so it's not just once a year I've got
those courses running year round
consecutively and I've removed all the
prerequisites so if a school owner wants
to hire someone tomorrow that student
can get into the next class whether it's
classroom methods in vehicle methods or
intro to Traffic Safety whatever the
next class is they can get in the owners
the school owners around the state are
able to hire in and and put new people
in much quicker than ever before and
we're seeing that I think I have 110
students in my classes right now some
are Vermont but majority are New
Hampshire students so I think it is like
160 driver education instructors now and
I'm I'm putting in I'm going to say
probably 70 or 80 more uh in you know in
three months time and it's a rotating
schedule so we have changed it it should
start making a difference out there on
the road as far as having enough
instructors to teach the class classes
of students and get them through faster
as well and hopefully reduce this
backlog that's been spoken of
um throughout
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my questions
I uh I had one um those courses that you
mentioned that your instructors are
required to take yes sir are those
um available for anyone today absolutely
and follow up
follow up thank you
um
would it be possible then for a
homeschooling parent or a homeschooling
group to take those courses and be
qualified any person can take those the
three courses that the state requires to
be certified as a driver education
teacher after you get your provisional
certificate you're required to work for
another driver education school for a
period of time before you can do your
own so to speak great thank you very
much
any other questions from the committee
representative sellers
yeah thank you Mr chair
the
what is the cost
for the students and what is the cost on
those courses the courses uh the new
hand the uh
White Mountain Community College per
credit is 235 right now so two of the
courses are 705 the third course is 8.55
because we have an in-person day that
they call a lab so that it brings it up
to 100
150 more and so the 23 60 2265 I think
for those three courses
follow up
and what does it cost for driver's ed at
this point for students every every uh
group is different or every school sets
their own uh I am currently at 800 at my
school in Littleton and
um it's just recognition of the cost for
insurance and cars and start paying this
instructors so I can keep them
um and that's that's where I am right
now
one more follow-up sorry sorry and how
long does a person have to work for
another driver's ed uh to be
self-sufficient they have to get what's
called a standard certificate before
they can go out on their own they have
to get a standard certificate so
normally the progression is during the
next two years that an instructor is
working they're asked to take five
additional courses three one credit
courses one three credit course alcohol
and drugs and a two credit course for
another type of driving course called
Zone control it's a more intensive uh
way of teaching so they're asked to take
those other five courses before they're
allowed to apply for a standard
certificate to to be on their own they
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman uh thank you for my additional
question is it still possible for
um a student who perhaps couldn't afford
the 800
um to wait the additional two years and
and take his driving exam without any
they can wait till they're 18 to take to
take driver education if they if they
wish to there are some things in the
works uh director marasco has been very
proactive and we're working on trying to
find ways to assist uh with tuition to
students who can't afford to get into a
program and we've been I'm part of a
driver task force that director marasco
has going and we we're working on trying
representative Sinclair thank you this
is for you Mr chair do we have anybody
that's going to speak from DMV or the
state police on this yes
thank you
okay not seeing on the further questions
thank you thank you thank you for your
time
chair and I now like to recognize
representative tolerski welcome back to
transportation
who's requesting four minutes who
thank you Mr chairman thank you
colleagues
um this bill House Bill 55 is word for
word the same exact bill as House Bill
1208 from last year which was tabled
which means I have a floor speech that I
never got to give
um outlining all the problems with this
bill but I will not go through it all
but I will touch on some of the
the bill does not specify what the
instruction would actually consist of
only that it is quote in person or
online
but I'd like you to compare that to the
driving schools that provide 30 hours of
classroom instruction with a defined and
approved curriculum from the Department
of Safety
the bill does specify 40 hours of behind
the wheel training however parents
already are required to spend 40 hours
with their teen behind the wheel
tracking these hours and stating which
skill was practiced and the bill really
has no other specifications outlining
the instruction
House Bill 55 keeps only the tip of the
iceberg of our existing program but
removes a large portion for those teens
who would get their license with a
waiver
they would not get the 10 hours in a
specially equipped vehicle driving with
a certified instructor as well as the
six additional hours observing other
students who are driving the benefit of
10 hours of dry direct instruction by a
professional who is up to date on safety
Technologies and best practices is clear
why are those observation hours so
important the more exposure you give a
teen to driving the more they learn it
allows students who see mistakes while
driving without being the nervous person
behind the wheel if something out of the
ordinary should happen on the road
because you can never recreate every
possible learning scenario more than one
student will be able to learn from that
experience it also helps a new driver
see that we all make mistakes and how to
learn from them
it's important that I'm clear that all
facets of the driver teen program are
vital and that includes parental
involvement parent instruction is
necessary and already incorporated into
the existing teen safety driver ed
program but removing the structured
structured classroom time with the
proven curriculum and 16 hours in a car
with a trained instructor is simply a
mistake and puts others on the road at
risk how do we know that
first we know that Nationwide vehicle
crashes Remain the leading cause of
death for teenagers and that's a fact
second
last year we had for the very first time
real data in a study
done of a similar law in Texas
the Texas Transportation Institute
showed us that teens taught by someone
other than a professional instructor are
more likely to be convicted of driving
violations including speeding
and they're more likely to be involved
in serious crashes
the study also found that these
parent-taught drivers are nearly three
times more likely to be involved in a
fatal crash
and were involved in nearly 50 percent
more crashes in which at least one
person received a severe injury
this study was provided to house
Transportation committee by Mr Goodman
with AAA and I assume he would be able
to supply the actual report to all of
you if not more updated information that
may have come up
since then
these accidents that are happening on
the roads are not just affecting a teen
driver in some kind of vacuum they're
affecting others on the roads with
life-altering accidents
this cannot be a matter of parent choice
or parent knows best when the
instruction given affects each and every
one of us every time we get in a vehicle
and I just want to hit on a few other
key points that I didn't have prepared
marks but the instructors
have strict standards for training
background checks driving record checks
continuing education and are up to date
on safety Technologies and best
practices compared to parents who
learned over 20 to 30 years ago I know
from taking driver's ed in 1986 to my
three children taking driver's ed from
2014 to 2020 the advances in safety
techniques and aggressive aggressive is
the wrong term but um
driving safely and and being you know
ready to react all of that has changed
second on the build new section
um I think it's five I can't read my
writing I have serious concerns with the
open-ended and questionable language
that is undefined the use of the term
responsible adult if a parent or
Guardian is not available I am very
interested to know what responsible
adult is and how that is um going to be
determined I also have problems with the
language that says the commissioner
shall waive driver's ed with no option
whatsoever to deny a waiver
third there are no details on what
provided for instruction either in
person or online actually means
um there is no control for the
Department to actually determine if the
instruction is meeting a certain minimum
standard
also I will wrap up with this I have
issues with the fact that the DMV says
in this fiscal note that a staff person
is going to need to be hired just to
deal with each and every one of these
waivers and I may suggest to the
committee that perhaps it would be more
beneficial to spend
um money and time to work with the DMV
on making schools more available and
more affordable and dealing with the
workforce issues to bring in driver's
instructors to solve the problem that
many of our communities are facing
but I will leave it there and I
apologize but I've left my own committee
to kind of testify and I unfortunately
don't have time to take questions
can I email it to the clerk yes thank
you
can chairman like to recognize John
Cameron
from the New Hampshire drivers education
Teachers Association
who's requesting three minutes who is in
it's checked off support
I will change that Mr chairman my name
is Tom Price I have a card would it be
okay if I testified together sure why
not
great thank you uh thank you chairman
Gorski members of the committee uh for
the record my name is Tom prasall from
Demers and praisal and I'm here today
representing the New Hampshire driver
education Teachers Association in
opposition to the bill and I'm here with
uh John Cameron who is the current
president of the New Hampshire driver
education Teachers Association
before you know John kicks off his
testimony I just wanted to address a
couple items I understand the reason for
the bill and I want the committee to be
clear that the New Hampshire driver
education Teachers Association as well
as the DMV have been working uh over the
last several years to to address a
number of the issues that were were
raised several years ago we worked on a
rule change to change the age at which a
student can begin driver education it
prior to that it was they had to be and
John will probably correct me if I'm
mistaken but they had to be 16 years old
at the conclusion of the course and we
modified the rules so that they can
begin the course when they are 15 years
and nine months and so that would have
opened up an additional class that the
student would be available to so we felt
that that was moving the ball in the
direction of creating more access to the
classes we've also a couple years ago we
were able to we worked with house in the
Senate to change the statute to allow
for up to 15 hours of the instruction
can be done via online or remote and we
have been working with the director on
determining what content could be done
in that manner
additionally recently we've been working
with the governor's office to create
opportunity for more driver education
teachers which
Mike Doucette had previously testified
to and I think that more driver out
instructors is the free market approach
to you know certainly drive down bring
competition drive down costs
um
and uh most recently uh two years ago
the national highway traffic safety
administration came in and uh did an
assessment of the New Hampshire driver
education program
um and moving to parentot was not one of
the recommendations I'd be happy to get
the committee a copy of that assessment
and additionally I do have a uh the
executive summary of the aforementioned
study that was done by Texas A M and the
transportation Institute with national
highway traffic safety administration
the full report is 216 pages so I saved
a couple trees and I can certainly email
that to the uh the committee with that
I'll turn it over to John for some
comments
thank you Mr chairman thank you
committee my name is John Cameron I'm
from Lebanon and with Twin State Driving
Academy and also the current president
of the New Hampshire driver's ed
Teachers Association
and I'm here speaking on behalf of them
in opposition of House Bill 55. I'm
going to try to Pare down what was my
written testimony that I was going to
read because other speakers have touched
on many of these points but just let me
go through a few the state of New
Hampshire has long placed a priority on
teen driver training has developed a
robust driver education training program
with the emphasis I was being on safety
um driver Educators go through extensive
training as you've heard and testing for
their state certifications this combined
with a specially equipped car lesson
plans and some infinite patients
provides a safe and knowledgeable
environment for a young teen to begin
the process of becoming a competent
driver
current standards for certified driver
education instructors including passing
as you heard eight college courses
specific to teaching driver education
passing a 100 question written exam
passing a road test completion of a
background and driving records check
meeting all the standards of safe C 3100
including an improved Curriculum lesson
plans route plans and more this bill in
effect potentially could make anyone who
has a driver's license a certified
driving instructor without meeting any
of these criteria
if this legislation were to pass I fear
that it would cause a number of driving
schools perhaps a significant number to
close leaving even more shortages of
professionals to provide traditional
training
access to classes is an issue the
industry as you've heard is actively
trying to address Department of Safety
along with members of the New Hampshire
driver Edge Teachers Association AAA and
other team members again are currently
meeting monthly with the director's
office to address these concerns New
Hampshire certified driving instructors
are the first line of defense in
promoting safety on our roadways for
everyone driving is the single most
dangerous thing we all do on a daily
basis
we all have licenses and each of us has
a different definition of what a good
driver is but I think we could all agree
that it's different out there than when
we learn to drive
it's more complicated than ever we have
more Vehicles than ever new technologies
and cars new roadway designs and safety
features and an ever increasing
population of drivers
there is a cost to taking class but that
cost is recoupable in the form of
discounts offered by insurance companies
for completing An approved driver
education course as driving instructors
we're held to standards that have and
have taken on significant costs our own
to become a pro approved schools
certified driving schools provide a
service to a small segment of our
population that service is as much about
the overall safety of our students and
the general population as it is about
the operation of a motor vehicle of
pushing pedals and turning Wheels
driving schools employ people who have
invested significant amount of money and
time within the state to be and remain a
certified instructor driving schools and
instructors are overseen by and work in
concert with the Department of Safety
for all these reasons we oppose House
Bill 55 and ask the committee to find
the bill in expedient to legislate we're
happy to answer any questions Mr
chairman if I can add one more just
brief comment one of the Hallmarks of
the New Hampshire driver education
program is the concurrency model which
requires that when you are in the
classroom and you're learning about a
specific technique or skill such as you
know going around rotaries the
concurrency model requires that when you
be going to the car with the instructor
that's exactly what you practice and I
think one of the the main concerns with
this legislation in in the name of
safety is that as it was mentioned there
really aren't any guard rails up
essentially somebody walks into the DMV
submits in writing and by saying
checking a box yes I completed the
driver education program and the
director or the commissioner shall Grant
the waiver I think that just creates a
lot of concern among the industry and uh
and for those reasons we opposed but
we'd be happy to take any questions
thank you any questions from the
committee representative Coker thank you
Mr chairman so as a driver instructor do
you you probably get a lot of children
that have driven with their parents
first correct it varies from some that
have done none to some that have been
quite a bit is it pretty easy to pick up
the bad habits pretty quickly like yep
yeah
teams will tend to drive you know like
their parents to start off with and I
think it's an eye-opener for parents too
when their teens take driver ed that the
teens go back to them and tell them hey
Mom hey Dad this is what we're learning
in driver's ed class and this is what
you know the the instructor had said is
the right way to do this and stuff so
it's it's an interesting uh experience
for everyone yeah thank you appreciate
it thank you
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
so with all of the rules changes that
the association has looked for and
changes I'm surprised
and and I'm curious why uh the idea of
not eliminating the option for a a New
Hampshire teen at 18 to have to apply
for their license with no driver ed why
that hasn't been a um a challenge for
the association
currently at 18 years old you don't need
to take Driver's Ed right yeah you just
go in and
take the road test and
so I so I guess I misunderstood or
misstated the question the question is
why wouldn't the if driver ed was was
the vital skill
um that everyone should have why would
we not try to get rid of
um the option for someone at age 18 to
not have dry red and still go in and and
attempt to get their license without any
driver ed instruction well thank you for
the question and representative if you'd
like to bring an amendment to replace
this with that I would be more than
happy to support that
um it hasn't been a discussion Point
okay thank you
any further questions representative
sellers
from 1618 they have to have a Driver's
Ed Course in order to drive once I turn
but you're saying that the I guess what
I'm hearing is and I'm trying to ask the
question
you don't
you don't trust any of the parents to
teach the kids how to drive I don't
understand why why the parents can't
teach them
I I don't think we would say that we
don't trust any parents to teach the
student Side Drive because currently in
state and law they are required to do 40
hours with with the student that's
already existing statute so I think we
would
say parents do have a responsibility to
be actively involved in driver education
follow-up follow-up so you're saying if
we amend this law to mend this bill to
say parents if you give a 120 hours of
time and 30 hours a classroom that you'd
be okay with it
I'm sorry maybe I don't understand the
question are you suggesting that I'm
saying parents teach the classroom as
well
parents do all the training I'm saying
if we allow the parents more time
instead of just this bill is asking for
40 hours and then classroom training
right instruction if we amended this
bill to say they have to give 80 hours
or 120 hours plus some classroom trading
would you be okay at that point at any
point would you be okay with parents
teaching their kids how to drive I I
think the main concern with this
legislation is a classroom instruction
being done by a professional who's been
trained to provide it
so I'm not sure that we would be okay
representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
is there a Prohibition fra for any
um Driving School currently in New
Hampshire for any child of a an
instructor an employee of that Driving
School to teach their children through
the driving school
if I understand talking about children
of driving instructors yes are they
still required to take the program no
are they are they prohibited from
teaching their own children there's no
prohibition that I know of right now no
thank you
okay I'm not seeing any further
questions thank you thank you
and I'll provide this to the clerk for
okay chair now like to recognize uh
Tracy
from the New Hampshire motorcycles
writers rights associ organization
who opposes the bill
she has some wrist and testimony she's
passing out and she's requesting three
minutes
thank you for your time uh chairman
Gorski today instead of Walsh and that
says that today since he's not here and
committee members
I'm Tracy borvage you've seen me here
before I'm the president of New
Hampshire motorcycle rights organization
and we do oppose this bill
uh about 20 years ago uh an hmro which
is our short term for New Hampshire
motorcycle rights organization
got legislation passed to include 45
minutes worth of motorcycle instruction
into the curriculum for driver's
education
that's important to motorcyclists
because having first-time drivers on the
road know how to ride in and around
motorcyclists what to do with us is very
important to us for motorcyclists
something else that I think you would
might find important we also got 45
minutes worth of the tractor-trailer
education input into the curriculum
because education is important to us as
motorcyclists
um one of the things I think that's very
important and I'm going to go a little
bit off of my testimony because I've
heard some of the testimony I'd like to
bring up is I don't believe that parents
I'm a motorcyclist I'm also obviously a
car driver
I do not think that parents especially
ones that have never been on a
motorcycle are going to know how to talk
to their children and train them on how
to ride in and around motorcyclists
uh because if you've never done
training on that which we have done we
were invited and we have spoken a couple
of times and are continuing to do so and
work with the driver instructors that
teach these classes and HMO has gone and
actually spoken to them we've talked to
them on the back page you'll see the
ride smart program that nhmro it's a
program that we came up with it's based
on information from data with fatalities
and crashes
we go and we speak to these driver
instructors that teach these kids about
what it means to ride in and around
motorcyclists how to do this how to do
it safely so that these Young Riders can
be safer riding in and around us
and I don't know if all of you have been
out in the roads but I'm sure you have
people are not writing very safe in and
around motorcyclists anymore
so we need to continue to teach our
children how to do that and nothing
against parents I'm a parent
I do not believe that I could teach my
child
the best practices
I'm 59 years old I got my license at 14
and a half and then 15 in South Carolina
I believe I'm a good driver
I've never had crashes or a speeding
ticket
but I don't think that I'm the best
person to teach my child how to drive
I do believe that it's important that I
participate in that but I believe that
someone that's been trained on driving
around motorcycles and tractor trailers
is far more better at doing that and
taking those classes and and teaching my
son or my daughter how to do that with
respect
to driving around other vehicles
I also wanted to bring up that we also
started the motorcycle riders education
fund nhmro did many many many years ago
the state now runs that and it's paid
for by motorcyclists we believe we're
big proponents in education we believe
in the safety of our roadways
and I just think it's important that you
you listen to all of this I'm someone
that's not from the Department of Safety
not from the DMV not from the
instructors we're writers
and we are out on the roads and we
believe in the safety and we believe in
the education that that safety brings
and when we teach in front of the
driver's instructors they're very
interactive with us they're asking
questions they want to know what the
motorcyclists need for us to teach them
so they can go back and teach these
youth so they can be safe around us
this is important
and there's no way to get all of that
out to parents there's no way
so I beg you to please listen
this is important
thank you
thank you so much any questions from the
committee
not seeing any thank you thank you for
I have two sets of cards from the DMV
and wondering if is the testimony going
to be different the same
uh
it'll be different yes okay
so we'll start off with
um chair like to recognize Adam Cooper
John Durand and Dem Leonard from the DMV
I don't have any
looks like there's no position on the
bill
good morning chairman
good morning committee my name is Adam
Cooper
my associates here John Duran Deb
Leonard we are all
licensing examiners for the State of New
Hampshire
we travel with your kids and your
grandchildren every single day
and we see a difference without
hesitation between the folks that have
driver's education the folks that do not
have driver's education
I did a quick analysis over the weekend
I do a report each week called our close
calls and it is simply a report that my
instruct my examiners give to me
this is a close call anytime you have to
grab the steering wheel
or
um intervene into a with a driver we
call that a close call
in the last three months I've had 124
close calls 86 of those close calls are
folks that are over 18 and have zero
Edge driver's education
so we do have folks that out there that
have education that are still dangerous
but they get extra training and we take
care of them all
thank you chair
um thank you committee I just wanted if
you don't mind a lot of things have been
touch base
um with some of the things I'd gone over
but just thinking about what the senator
brought forward
um like one thing with the teaching with
the Flying Nun I would assume the Flying
Nun had some sort of
you know background and how to teach
driver's ed so he did get that
opportunity where you were not going to
get that with parents I think some of
our biggest fears is when you have the
parents teaching the parents are going
to teach their bad habits which we see
on the road
um many times when you get in the car
with these people you can right from the
gecko you can feel it as they're driving
the lack of experience the lack of time
behind the wheel it's hard enough with
the program we have now that
um sometimes we don't really you can
the parents are not always taking them
out for 40 hours they're just writing
that they do parents today unfortunately
work two jobs they're very busy you know
so I'm a very big uh very very poached
to this
um
we have a lot of close calls out there
and biggest thing bottom line is when
you get finished a test I want to feel
in my heart if I put this person on the
road are they gonna
hurt themselves hurt my family hurt your
family that's our biggest thing is
safety we really want to you know
emphasize that so thank you for your
time
yeah sorry
thank you for your time my name is Deb
Leonard and I'm a licensed examiner down
in Dover and I've been there for eight
years
first and foremost it's safety I
have concerns over that bill
um I can't speak highly enough of the
driver education classes that I work
with
schools that I work with Excuse me of
teaching these kids how to drive
many times after each and every road
test I touch or have a contact with the
parents or the guardians or their
support drivers and many times as I'm
going over the positive or negative
things that happened on that road test
the parents or Guardians themselves are
saying oh I didn't realize we needed to
Signal there I didn't realize we needed
to look over a shoulder there
and I did have a young applicant just
two weeks ago who was doing almost 18
miles an hour over the speed limit
and when we get back we talked about the
dangers and the safety issue and that
and the parents said well I apologize
but she's learned that from her dad her
dad is a really fast driver and that's
where she learned it from so that would
be my concern again I'm not saying that
all parents are like that or that would
be a concern but it's it's having that
education or that all this information
they need to
be able to teach these kids so
thank you any questions from the
committee representative Coker
thank you Mr chairman
um so can you describe a little bit the
post if somebody fails their driving
test what is kind of the remedial
program after that look like or is it
kind of like just go back figure it out
and come back and perform or I can
answer for myself
I can answer for myself is that I take
that time in that vehicle with that
applicant I write out notes of
everything that they and their parents
or Guardians can work with and then I
automatically speak with that license
their support driver to make sure that
um
everything everything that's gone on on
that road test I have written out and
worked with them on do you have any like
oh sorry can I follow follow-up um do
you have any statistics on what the pass
rate is for the second time around I
mean do you see Improvement normally or
huge huge okay because I've taken that
time and I've worked with the parents or
the Guardians and the kids if I can
build that rapport with them and try to
go over those safety issues of what I
saw that needs to be worked on
and I have a lot of parents that come
back and say thank you so much you you
took that time with me I didn't realize
we needed to do all of this stuff okay
thank you appreciate it
representative Sinclair
thank you when you have those close
calls does that stop the test and
they're they they have to take it over
again
yes we have the option to stop it at any
time if it's the dangerous situation and
we will uh then take over and bring the
applicant back to the DMV
um so yeah we do have the option to stop
the test
um look depends on the infraction
sometimes I like to finish the test to
then see what else they may need work on
but we have the option to stop anytime
okay thank you representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
uh the the concerns that you have
um as an inspectors or is that
could it be centered on classroom or
um on driving or both or how where is
the where is the problem centered
it's definitely both it's definitely
both they they really need that
classroom time
um to really get get like they were
saying earlier you you have a classroom
they go through say they go through just
for this we're going to work on rotaries
then the nice part about that is you'll
leave the classroom and then they'll be
working on rotaries in the vehicle with
the instructor it's just um
it's it's such a huge difference just in
a matter of how they handle the vehicle
representative sellers give us a chair
how do you handle
um Asylum Seekers
that are getting licensed are immigrants
that are getting licenses that don't
yeah um same thing it's because the law
is 18 so anybody over 18 doesn't need
the driver's education so they come in
uh we have a very high failure rate
there too part of it is a language issue
and and some of the signage is not
always the same sometimes they drive on
the left side from where they're from
and that so there is a high failure rate
then and then
um but same thing as um
as Miss Leonard said when you go through
the test with them
um you tell them where they need work we
have magazines we hand out we can teach
them on the with the magazine that you
need to do this this and this and and uh
usually you know
sometimes takes two three times but you
know they get it again biggest factors
follow-up
so thank you Mr would you say that at
this point there any would you say the
worst would they be worse than
students at 16 years old being taught by
parents
are they
worse drivers uh taking a test or not no
not well it depends I mean you get you
get people who come here and they're
very good drivers they're from you know
depends what where they come from and
and that I mean so many of them are very
good drivers and experience so you know
you can have somebody coming in their
30s and 40s and they've been driving for
quite a few years so they uh it's not
it's not an issue so I don't really have
any numbers of you know which
particulars would would be but there are
many who do Drive well because they have
been driving for quite a bit it's more
the when you get back to the the people
who don't go to Driver's Ed and are from
this country and at 18 they wait till 18
then it's a it's a little different
because they don't have the experience
like a person who came from another
country that you know has been driving
but again you can get somebody from
another country and we don't we don't
know what their Driving Experience is
they may never have drove before you
know but it I don't know if you're
familiar they have three times to fail
then after that they have to go to
get driving instruction by a you know a
professional then they can come back and
return
in regards to your question um coming
from another country who automatically
seek driver education if it be it one
hour two hour three hour driving just so
they are prepared coming in because they
aren't aware of all the rules of the
okay nuts
okay we're falling behind go ahead
representative Sinclair so if you're 18
years old and you fail the test three
times then you're required to take
driver's ed
it
so we'll fill out a little fill out some
paperwork that shows the results of
those three tests that you have failed
and then we'll present you a hearing and
at that hearing it's up to the DMV and
the state to decide how many additional
hours or education that that individual
may need generally on the first
opportunity it's 10 additional hours of
drive time and five addition hours of
classroom and then if they have for some
bad reason they go another six three
tests then the education doubles
for the questions thank you thank you
thanks again for your time chair now
like to recognize John marasco and Mike
Mercier
from the New Hampshire DMV who opposed
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee John marasco director of The
Division of Motor Vehicles and driver
licensing supervisor Michael Mercier
will be very brief
representative tolerski through her
remarks highlighted all of those safety
concerns that we would have spoken about
um just for the committee we all are
working towards reducing wait times for
young people that want to get into
driver's ed we know that that's
something we we want to improve upon
lowering the cost for students that want
to take Driver's Ed and increasing the
number of schools and instructors
throughout the state to allow for um for
those things to take place I just want
to let you know that we do have a
monthly meeting with the driver's ed
Community we're actively working with
the community on rule changes we
actually had a conversation this morning
we have some rule changes that will help
driver-red schools around the state and
those are with legal and we're still
having talks on getting those over the
Finish Line in the very short term
um and we're also working with the
governor's office on additional funding
that would be beneficial to
getting more driver instructors through
their certification process and into
these schools so the examiners here
they're doing this work each and every
day and they see the difference between
a young person who comes in that's
completed Driver's Ed versus somebody
that hasn't so with that I just wanted
to offer that to the committee and turn
it over to Mike
hi uh Mr chair members of the committee
thank you for having us here today
um
just wanted to reiterate uh about some
of the examiners being a former law
enforcement officer and also a former
Examiner I can tell you that I would
much rather be in a car with a 16 17
year old who's had driver's ed as
opposed to an 18 or above who has not
had driver's ed
the incidence of close calls that we
talked about earlier are fairly high and
people who are 18 years and older and
that's because they learn to drive with
friends you know because they're a legal
age because they can join the military
you know we don't enforce the the
driver's ed rule on them but they also
go out they don't actually train with
their parents if they don't have them
available they may train with friends
people who don't really know all of the
rsas for for instance for driving
so the incidents are higher for them to
fail as opposed to the driver's
education students between 16 and 17.
thank you Mike we're happy to take any
questions thank you any questions from
the committee
representative Sinclair thank you have
have you attempted to
take information or data on drivers
between the ages of 16 and 21 who have
been in accidents so you can see if
they've actually taken drivers that are
not
yeah so actually uh Mike has been
working for some time on um uh working
through one of our our contractors our
technology contractors to look at all
the numbers for
um at the very least passage rates at
the DMV
um for those that have Driver's Ed
versus those that don't
um we know that people that have
driver's ed fare better when they come
to the DMV for their exam as far as
crashes go I think what representative
telers both spoke to as far as what we
see Nationwide you know as far as
crashes among young people that's that's
that and you know data is there have we
actually drilled down and done that at
the DMV I'm not aware if we have not
between the ages of 16 and 21. we
haven't looked at that study at all I
hope you do sometime thank you thank you
sir representative sellers
thank you Mr so the area I live in in we
have to drive 30 miles to go to a
driver's ed class and that's if we can
get it scheduled because it's a it's
literally almost a year out
and and you're saying you're changing
how the train driver ed teachers how are
you doing that and how much shorter will
it be I mean I heard that I'd have to go
work for somebody for two years before I
could actually work on my own on my by
myself as my own business
it's a very good question it really is
um those are the conversations that
we're we're working through
um you know we do have the DMV rule set
that governs certain aspects of driver's
ed
um there are the those are some of the
changes that we're looking to make to
expedite
um some of these processes to make it
more flexible for driver ed schools and
bringing more instructors on
um you know view online training uh is
something that has been discussed and
will continue to be discussed both the
RSA portion of it and the rule set I
think there's a lot of opportunity here
to drive down some of these areas that
we're trying to make gains on and I
think we have all the right people right
now at the table to include uh to
include the governor's office and again
that conversation that we had Friday
with representative Moffett and with
Senator Lang very productive I think we
all want the same thing so some of those
things that you're talking about sir we
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman thank you uh director for
coming and talking with us
um you mentioned driving down costs um
no pun intended but did um did you is
that with the answer that you just gave
is that where you're thinking the cost
savings are going to be and online or
something like that yeah I think there's
uh from a from a student standpoint
there's a couple different forces at
play there one of which would be
um if we're able to secure some funding
that would allow driver instructors to
actually go through the 15-week training
and do that free of charge that might
incentivize more people to actually want
to become instructors and um and that's
going to obviously open up more
opportunities for young people to have
an instructor to work with and some of
those instructors will go on and
actually open their own schools down the
road so
um from a Marketplace standpoint that's
a good solution that being said we've
all also to include last Friday had some
open-ended conversations about is there
any money available that could
potentially go into a fund that young
people could draw from that would
actually offset the cost of driver's ed
so you come at it from the drivers ed
instructor angle but also come at it
from uh you know a fund that might be
able to uh to offset some of the costs
for for young people so that just came
up on Friday as far as from a state
standpoint but but these are all ideas
that are being discussed right now and I
think that we do want to do our best to
try to drive down the cost for the end
user as best we can I think there are
some ways to do it
thank you sir
representative sellers oh
oh sorry representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um looking back at the history of why
states were compelled to create or
acquire Driver's Edge programs does that
give us any insight into what the
concerns would be going back to
um you know homeschooling of drivers
young drivers thank you representative
for that question it's a great one I do
know that we have Trooper first class uh
Rich DuPont from the state police he
actually oversees the driver's ed
program throughout the state on behalf
of the DMV he did submit a card I
believe to to testify he can speak a
little bit more than I can about the
historical perspective
thank you
okay not seeing any other questions
thank you thank you sir and speaking of
TFC Richard DuPont
call him up he's representing New
Hampshire State Police he opposes the
bill
he's asked for five minutes if you keep
up to two to three would be much
appreciated
okay
thank you
Trooper Rick Dupont I represent the
department of safety and I do oppose
um the Department of State safety takes
a position that um
in the past we would like to present
that in the past the state of New
Hampshire
and the state legislature spoke to the
quality of our state's program when they
created it and what that program should
look like can be found in part in rsa's
263 19 in an RSA 21 p14 which speaks to
the development of the rules and the
rsas relating to driver's education
School courses schools in the
qualifications of their instructors
at that time the state legislature
together with the New Hampshire to
driver's education Association who spoke
today in the Department of Education and
the New Hampshire Division of Motor
Vehicles developed a quality program to
have certified instructors teach our
young drivers how to properly and safely
operate a motor vehicle upon the
roadways of New Hampshire
this program has been successful for
many years
it would stand a reason that most
parents are not professional instructors
they're parents and are seemingly not
attempting to become professional
instructors and part of this house bill
however the process to become a
professional instructor is important in
that the level of training they
initially received is college level
and the level they are expected to
maintain for their certification is
important like a teacher they have to
have professional development as well to
maintain their certification each school
and each instructor is held to a
standard above a normal person in the
driver education program they teach to
our young drivers is a quality program
that our state has benefited for many
years
a parent with good intentions cannot
replace a professional trained
instructor to teach how to keep our
roads safe and I really think that
should be the focus of this
um in 2021 our our program our state
went through a an assessment program
um we had these nationally certified
um people that came in they assessed our
program and thought that it was one of
the better programs in our country
so I think that stands a lot for the New
Hampshire
at that time they were using the numbers
at three to five percent of our young
drivers were actually involved in fatal
accidents at the time which when you
consider how many the the number we have
now it's pretty low
and I attribute that a lot to his
driver's education
in our integrated format which is uh one
of the quality portions of the program
and I know that they you know they spoke
about it earlier you learn it in the
classroom and then you go out and you
apply it on the roadway and it's done in
this some people use the term concurrent
the law the rule says integrated format
but that's super important to make sure
that our roadways and our young drivers
Department of Safety has a few concerns
with the house bill
regarding the implementation of the
house bill
some of the some of the concerns are the
age and driving experience of the
individual individuals sorry providing
the instruction
it could that age could vary it doesn't
mean that it's going to be a 30 year old
person that could be an 18 year old
person
um and who will be reviewing the driving
records and how will a parent receive
approval that was brought up earlier
um in the beginning testimony of how
would it that a per a parent or a
responsible driver could go through an
um then there was the the question of
the commission commissioner shell uh
waive requirements and instead of the
using the term May so how would that
approval process work I'm not really
sure and how would that waiver process
work again not really sure
um
the documentation submitted uh by the
parents or responsible adults
does not require the submission of what
the curriculum was is it going to be in
keeping with the the program that is
actually in effect today and that our
driving schools are actually using
utilizing every single day to teach our
drivers in a consistent manner
um
the does this this program go with the
current law of RSA 26319 which includes
all the 30 hours of classroom and behind
the wheel time the observation time 45
minutes
um of instruction of how to drive around
a commercial motor vehicle or 45 minutes
of instruction on how to drive around
motorcycles that's a state law and how
do we make sure that this is all being
taken care of correctly
uh the oversight the vetting of their
programs
not really sure how that's going to be
addressed
this this house bill will result in
parents instructing
um at various levels of Competency some
of whom may have never taken driver's
the laws and rules as they are at this
time allow for a quality driver
education program to be delivered
consistently to our young drivers by
trained and certified instructors
ultimately keeping our so our roadway
safe
any proposed changes to the position
from from should be from my position of
safety not convenience over safety
I've been a police officer for 18 years
and I have unfortunately had to respond
to
accident scenes I've had to see the
results of some fatalities
I've also
have been passed last year I was passed
am I fully my cruiser by 20 adults
and it's a fully my cruiser I've been
tailgated several times by parents or
potential parents
and I'm not so sure that I know that
some parents aren't they're going to
have the best of intentions but I would
caution that
parents are out on our roadways and
teaching their children bad habits in
our driving instructors are what's is
keeping our roadway safe and correcting
those bad habits thank you very much
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative sellers thank you Mr
chair would you accept any bill or any
amendment to this bill or any Bill like
this so a parent could actually teach
their child
I got the look
um ultimately at the end of the day
we're open to discuss uh you know any
improvements to the house bill as it
sits but I think as you heard prior
testimony that our uh our thoughts still
align with having certified instructors
be the one that performed the the
instruction
representative
thank you for taking that question thank
you Mr chairman
um I'll go back to the question I asked
before is there any evidence in
in history of why you know States
started requiring driver's education
that would give us insight into what we
would be seeing if we went back to a you
know self-taught or homeschool type of
program
thank you representative for the
question
um that I'm not familiar with but I can
give you some insight into the
historical perspective very briefly on
the program and and kind of give you
some indicators as to why we are where
we are so historically the Department of
Education was involved in concert with
the Department of Safety and providing
oversight to the driver education
program throughout the state and in
recent years the Department of Education
has been removed from that and part of
that was funding that was that fell
under the driver training fund so
essentially when you buy a vanity plate
there's 40 fee that is attached to that
that goes into this driver training fund
that driver training fund over the
course of number of years provided a
reimbursement to the schools which then
fell back onto the children and the
reason for that was when Department of
Education was involved in it the program
was required by the state at the high
school level so when you hear people
speaking to taking their driver
education program through their high
schools it was required at that time by
the state date and accordingly the state
reimbursed 150 dollars per student that
went back to the school that helped
offset the price of driver education to
the students at that time now fast
forward to today where that has been
removed and that reimbursement has been
removed as well and as you know with the
rising cost of fuels car and everything
insurance that falls upon now the driver
Educators you know they still have
absorbed a lot of that cost but
unfortunately you know without that
reimbursement there we just don't have
that ability right now to to uh to
offset that cost that's what I know as
okay last one representative Hill
thank you Mr chairman um quick question
is
um are any of the driving driver ed
classes available in anything other than
English
currently
most of our school the majority of our
schools it's all in English I do know
that Nashua in the southern part of the
state does have a program and they're
starting to really gear towards having
it in Spanish but right now it's
predominantly in English but that has
been on my my radar for a while and I've
actually asked the driver's education
Community what languages do they do
their instructors speak so that if we do
receive which we do receive the phone
calls
um hey I speak French or I only speak
Spanish where can I go I can at least
send them in the direction of a school
that actually has an instructor that can
we speak that language and try and help
that Community I know that there's uh
African communities right now are trying
to
um
gain ground and traction and try and
start their own schools to help teach
um their young drivers driver's
education because some of them have
never been behind a wheel of a car in
the first place and now they're just
then you have the dialects on top of
that so we are working our offices
working with those organizations to try
and help facilitate driver's education
in that direction
thank you yes sir
okay I'm not seeing any questions thank
you very much for your time
I do not have any more pink cards so
this officially closed a hearing on HB
55 our next bill will be HB 137 we'll
get it started in about two to three
minutes
all right be at 11 23 we're falling a
little bit behind but uh let's start the
public hearing
on HP 137 at this point I'd like to
recognize
representative Jim Creighton the Bill's
sponsor
and 137 is relative to boating safety
equipment rules and vessel numbering
rules and establishing a committee to
study boat registration fees
thank you Mr chair thank you committee
members I appreciate your time this
afternoon
um HP 137 7 stems from an inner interim
study bill last year HP one six four one
uh in essence the state of New Hampshire
is currently
um not abiding by federal regulations
um in terms of the way it collects and
distributes voter registration fees
the purpose of 137 is to establish and
solidify a committee that will look at
how to bring New Hampshire under Federal
Regulation and the interim study felt
that we weren't able to do that last
year and we needed until November of
this year
if this if we do not fall under Federal
Regulation then we lose Federal funding
uh the Coast Guard has said has given us
time to do this and believes that if we
establish this committee to move forward
uh that we can in fact
um achieve the federal standard
simultaneously we're working with
Senator Shaheen's office to change the
law at the federal level there are seven
other states that are out of compliance
with these laws
the issue stems from the distribution of
the registration funds the funds
currently go to the Peace Commission the
fish and game department and the
department of Des
um
and that is in contravention to federal
law and so what we're trying to do is
bring New Hampshire into compliance of
federal law on one hand on the other
hand we're trying to change the federal
law through Senator Shaheen so that we
come into compliance
um either way the state cannot afford to
lose the money associated with the
um with being out of compliance with
these laws so this bill essentially
brings New Hampshire up to date with
federal law and uh Captain dunlavy
um of the of the Marine Patrol uh is the
one that's the honcho in this and has
been working with a wide variety of
people to make this happen
so our subject to your questions that's
uh the introduction of this bill
thank you so much any questions from the
committee representative Hill thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
question thank you
um how much are we uh getting from
federal funds and and what parts of the
lar are we out of compliance with uh
that's a great question I would defer to
Captain Dunleavy who has a specifics on
that
representative sellers thank you Mr
chair what are these federal funds used
for
so they they help support those three
agencies
um in their in their daily day functions
so the fishing game relies on them Des
relies on them and the Peace Commission
also rely on those funds for day-to-day
operations
follow-up yes follow-up thank you chair
Mr chair
are there any strings attached to the do
these um
I guess divisions or departments do they
have to do certain meet certain
obligations to have that money
uh not to my knowledge that that money
comes in through the voter registration
goes back out for the intended purposes
any other questions from the committee
like I now like to recognize
representative Mike Edgar
who supports the bill with concerns
thank you Mr chair and committee for
hearing me you say a few words
for a minute and uh basically uh there
obviously is a reason to have this bill
it was just explained uh just to have uh
some concerns uh in some of it's related
to the
to the list of groups that are going to
be consulted by this uh five person
panel so
um again I represent Hampton I have some
concerns uh that basically that the
title or Seacoast will be you know
legitimately represented on this
committee and hopefully with the members
that are appointed it will be spread out
between let's say Inland and in title uh
groups and uh maybe even we could uh get
the senator that has both on here to to
enable that to be you know again to be
fair
um
we have uh some um some other groups and
maybe it would be good to consider and
maybe we can just talk to the people who
are who are running this when it happens
there's there's not very many months to
uh to complete this study and as we know
sometimes during the summer it's like
August the Committees don't meet either
but I didn't realize that there already
was an interim study so hopefully
they're somewhat Along on this already
and that they they would be able to meet
with the groups all the groups both both
the title and Inland maybe have some
additions to the group that that that's
listed right here right now but it to me
it seems it's somewhat aggressive and I
I know it's going to be a Heavy Haul for
are there any questions for me
any questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you okay thank you
very much
jira now like to recognize
representative Rebecca McBee
who's representing Portsmouth who does
good morning it's nice to see you all it
really is I yeah I think the two years
in remote I don't know a lot of you so
it's nice to meet you
um I do support the bill and I applaud a
representative Creighton and others that
have worked on this issue in the past
the bill really has two parts the first
part is the establishment of the study
committee which would be for members of
the house and one Senate and I think our
concerns my concerns with that is that
we do have appropriate representation of
both the inland waterways the freshwater
and the title being assault
and this the second part of the bill it
names the stakeholders which the five
members of the study committee will
consult with and I'd like to for the
committee or the sponsors to consider
adding some additional folks to that I
mean I just went through very briefly
but I think we've got the division of
ports and harbor Council but the New
Hampshire Port advisory committee the
peas
Development Authority and the director
of the port which you will talk with
later but so thank you it is good to see
you and I'm just a good representation
of you know all of our water in New
Hampshire on this committee
thank you thank you any questions from
the committee
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you
chair now I'd like to recognize Gino
Marconi who representing the port
authority
uh who supports the bill and is
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee uh Gino maricone I'm the
director of the
peas Development Authority division of
ports and harbors uh but we do
businesses the New Hampshire Port
Authority real quickly the Port
Authority was established in 1957 by the
legislature and in 2001 we were merged
administratively with the peace
Development Authority we are a separate
entity-ended peas and we are so funding
which is why this uh this study
committee is important to us because
we get some of those revenues from boat
registrations I will say that our chief
Harbor Master who couldn't be with us
today worked with Captain dunlavy and
his group bringing forward some of the
concerns that we may have in supporting
Captain Dunleavy in his prior prior work
on this issue
um but I will Echo what uh the two
representatives from the Seacoast say uh
that uh the last line in in uh
the list of uh people that are uh called
upon to uh participate and and give
information to the study committee it
does say whomever else may be uh needed
to to provide information I hope that uh
I wanted to put it into the record that
we would ask that other groups on the
Seacoast area because up until now uh
we've kind of been the soul voice and we
just would like to have other people
that we know that are knowledgeable in
the Boating activities on the Seacoast
uh that they have an opportunity to uh
be reached out to and consulted on this
and I'll leave it at that Mr chairman
thank you so much uh any questions from
the committee
not seeing any thank you very much thank
you sir thank you members of the
committee
chair now would like to recognize John
Wiley Wally
from the New Hampshire Marine trades
Association
who is going to support the bill
good morning thank you I'm John Wally
the general manager of Silver Sands
Arena a family-owned Marina of three
generations in Guilford New Hampshire
and also the president of the New
Hampshire Marine trades Association and
the interim trade Association is the
association of marine related businesses
that are here to protect and see the
growth of recreational building in the
state of New Hampshire we see ourselves
as stewards as in taking care of the
legs protecting the environment and also
the beauty of our resources
we are here to support House Bill 137 in
the critical to review the voting
registration laws in later the coast
guards determination that we're
non-compliant with federal regulations
and therefore we'll risk funding for the
State Marine Patrol
many of our members are ages for the
State of New Hampshire for boat
registrations and do registrations for
customers and also general public we
have concerns that the voters will have
limited potentials and also Rising costs
in potential registrations moving
forward he may choose the boat in other
places because of those costs
uh many families have choices what are
they going to do and how they're going
to recreate New Hampshire in the
summertime and we look forward to
concerns that hindering existing
programs and also impacting
affordability will dramatically affect
the Hampshire in the voting so we
support House of 137 and we are
committed to helping the state
legislature in any way to move forward
with these issues thank you
thank you so much any questions from the
committee
chair now I'd like to recognize uh
Andrea La Moreau
from the New Hampshire Lakes
hopefully I didn't put your name too bad
thank you
um supports the bill we're uh asking for
good morning and thank you for this
opportunity and I won't take three
minutes
um New Hampshire Lakes uh we are a
Statewide non-profit organization our
mission is to restore and preserve the
health of our Lakes we're here to
support
hb137 you've heard that the issue
um this the additional fees that are
collected currently when someone
registers their boat in New Hampshire
these fees go to support a number of
critical programs I'm here to talk to
you about one particular program
fees go to the lake restoration fund
through this Lake restoration fund a
number of things happen but I'm going to
speak on the support for aquatic
invasive species prevention and control
so a great so New Hampshire Lakes we run
a Statewide a courtesy boat inspection
program you might have heard of it the
lake host program we over the past 20
years have met about 1.5 million voters
at about a hundred of the most busiest
boat ramps in the state
and taught them how to take simple
actions to clean drain and dry their
boats to prevent the spread of unwanted
plants and animals you might have heard
of milfoil before obviously preventing
the spread of invasive species is is
good for the ecology but it's also good
for for anyone who wants to use the
Lakes they invasive species are
dangerous they cause Recreation trouble
difficult to drive your boat
once you get an invasive species it's
very expensive to manage nearly
impossible to get rid of and obviously
clean invasive free Lakes are really
important for our economy
so this bit this program that we run is
supported by the grant through a grant
supported by these fees and we really
are asking for some time for the state
the committee to figure this out and
also possibly solutions to be figured
out on the federal level other states
that have split out to these costs
Unfortunately they have seen large
reductions in revenues coming in for
their invasive species management and we
just can't afford for that to happen
here in New Hampshire
uh so I urge you to support this bill
and happy to answer any questions
thank you so much any questions from the
committee
representative Hill do you know how much
money currently goes to your
organization for this from those fees
collected I'm sorry how much how much
the New Hampshire Lakes gets for so uh
New Hampshire Lakes we apply for a grant
from Des and that Grant is just under
three hundred thousand dollars every
year and then we leverage an additional
nearly eight hundred thousand dollars in
local support great thank you great
question
any other questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you so much thank
chair now like to recognize Roger grow
who's the chairman of the New Hampshire
Port of Port advisory committee
who supports the bill
with an amendment and is asking for
good morning Mr chairman members of the
board
um my name is Roger grow I'm the
chairman of the New Hampshire Port
Authority advisory committee that
committee exists on this statute and is
regulated by that statute
um
I've been on that committee for 10 years
and I wonder while we were working with
Captain Dunleavy
there's no mention of us in the bill and
we want to make sure we have a seat at
the table
um our area of responsibility are
the Great Bay the little Bay uh all the
title estuaries
the port of Portsmouth Little Harbor Rye
Harbor Hampton Harbor Seabrook Harbor
so we have quite a bit of territory
we're responsible for
as well as the state fish piers in
Hampton and in Portsmouth
um
we have commercial boaters that we
represent as well as the recreational
ones and there's more to boating in New
Hampshire than just the Lakes boaters
and I would
urge you to uh
to amend the bill to make sure that we
have a seat at the table and I will
remind you that the state flag has a
picture of a sailing ship and it was
built in Portsmouth so there is more to
life than like Winnipesaukee
uh I would take any questions anybody
has any
any questions from the committee
representative sellers thank you Mr
chair
it's um it's not saying that they you
don't have input and and they the study
committee cannot won't ask you so I
would expect to reach out to everybody
and anybody that would be helpful
putting the study together when so I
don't know if it needs to be amended or
not well we just want to make sure we're
seated at the table because the list of
potential people is very heavily
weighted towards uh Inland voters all
right and his as representative mcbeath
mentioned uh we just want to make sure
that we have a representation from the
Seacoast both in the in the legislators
appointed to that committee and in where
they're taking testimony from
um that's
that's
my mission today so
any other questions any other questions
from the committee
not seeing any thank you so much all
I like to recognize uh representative
Tim mcgow
um representing Merrimack who is in
supporting the bill and requesting one
minute
thank you Mr chairman representative Tim
McGill from Merrimack and I'll just take
a quick minute to show up in support of
this bill I just learned this bill this
weekend actually uh when some colleagues
around and friends and colleagues around
Silver Lake and uh one of my
fellow members from Merrimack a
co-sponsor representative Healy told me
about this bill and I think it's a great
idea and I applaud the sponsors for
making it a short study committee with
the report due just this year in
November so it won't drag on I think
it's a great idea to study how the use
of these fees can be efficiently used
and I definitely support and I'd be
happy to serve on that study committee I
currently serve on resources and we have
an interest in this area as well and I
hope the transportation committee looks
favorably on this bill I'm a lifelong
boat owner both a power boater and
currently a sailboat owner there's a lot
of important issues addressed in this
bill
including how the Coast Guard fees are
currently used and how they might be
used in the future
so really that's all I wanted to say I
know that the Silver Lake Association
supports the bill I'm not sure if they
were already here apologies for my late
arrival and some of the other Lake
Associations so I hope you look
favorably on the bill and I'd be happy
to be one of the legislative members to
serve on this committee and and study
the issues during the summer and get a
report out quickly duly noted
any questions
from the committee not seeing any thank
and the channel I would like to
recognize uh Tim dunlevy from the state
police Marine control
who is in support of the bill and is
thank you Mr chair honorable members of
the transportation committee my name is
Tim Dunleavy I'm a program specialist
with the Marine Patrol unit of the State
Police recently retired Captain I'm here
this morning with the new Bureau
commander of unit Commander Dennis Wade
who's in the back for moral support
I come to you this morning in support of
this bill and to provide provide you
with a little background information
the New Hampshire Marine Patrol receives
approximately 1.7 million dollars
annually
that is part of the recreational boating
safety fund the national recreational
voting safety fund distributed by the
Coast Guard
the receipt of those funds like many
federal funds is contingent upon
participation in various Federal
programs
and and one of those programs is the
national boat registration laws
during a recent desk audit of our
program the Coast Guard comes around to
each state every two years
and they discovered that at the time we
register boats in our state
we are violating federal law
when we collect funds for
the Des Lake restoration fund the fish
and game search and rescue fund the fish
and game Public Access fund and the peas
ports and harbors dredging fund
those funds for which we collect money
at the time of boat registrations are
not acceptable under federal statute
and the Coast Guard has identified that
and put us on notice that until we
correct that we are jeopardizing our
annual disbursement of the recreational
voting safety Monies
so after working closely with the r d
committee last year in an interim study
explaining to them the background and
the issues related to the collection of
those funds we come before you today uh
asking for this study Commission
it is to look at not where these funds
are being spent
but how are we going to make up for the
collection of these funds that we are
collecting illegally
through the boat registration process
that is the issue at hand and and beyond
that if you get into the weeds uh it
becomes a little more uh complicated
because there are multiple agencies
involved that receive these critical uh
funds for their programs
in addition this bill does ask for the
authority uh in rule making for the
commissioner of safety to recognize
current
code of federal regulations as it
pertains to definitions
um
the industry boating industry like every
industry right now technology is taking
off faster than what our lawmakers can
keep up with
electric power for one is is is uh is on
the verge in the Boating Market as well
efoils I can go on down the list
and currently in New Hampshire it is
structured so that anytime there is a
new
uh creation of a new vessel
new equipment changing equipment
requirements it needs to come before you
for those changes
but in the automotive side of the house
commercial vehicle side of the house
the legislature has just authorized the
commissioner to recognize those changes
that occur with the federal statutes for
those specific areas
and so we're just asking for
essentially a housekeeping issue that'll
allow the state to keep up with the
terms and Trends in the industry by
recognizing Federal code
I've passed around a reference sheet
to you so that you can specifically look
at those definitions and where in the
federal statutes they are so that you
can see it's only addressing definitions
of a personal watercraft so that we
don't have our own or if oils they've
changed the labels to life jackets
recently
uh we're calling them type one two three
four and five they're now done by a
number assignment so it's those types of
things that that are housekeeping in
nature with this bill
and then the study committee as we've
we've said related specifically to the
collection of these revenues for our
partner agencies
as far as the membership or who you
solicit information from certainly we
did recognize uh the ports and harbors
and his director or designee because of
that dredging fund along with Fish and
Game Des
I'm happy to entertain any questions you
may have at this time
thank you so much any questions from the
committee representative Hill thank you
Mr chairman and thank you for taking my
questions
I'd like to get the numbers right so I I
think I heard you say 1.75 million
um that is federal funding that we we
received that would be jeopardized if we
continue to collect boat fees and
distribute it the way we currently
distribute it is that correct yes sir
it's it's it likely would be a
percentage because the registration
program
that we are required to
um engage in with the feds is only one
portion of that 1.7 million there's also
accident reporting that we we uh are
required to submit to the feds which
which we do annually so I I anticipate
if the feds would say New Hampshire
you haven't changed things we're taking
away your money it would be a percentage
um
follow up follow up
so um of the
of the money that we collect currently
for boat registrations how much how much
is that that gets distributed amongst
all of those different those three or
four different organizations
how much is how much in both fees are we
Distributing so
um and I know Des will correct me I'm
wrong I think it's 950 per vote that we
register goes to Des for the lake
restoration fund and you can use a rule
of thumb in New Hampshire recently if
you can't figure out a hundred thousand
boats a year registered in New Hampshire
that that's a fairly accurate number so
950 per boat
one dollar per boat goes to the fishing
five dollars per boat
goes to the fishing game Public Access
fund which is your ramp repairs and and
uh Construction
and two dollars per boat goes to the
dredging fund uh overseen uh by the
folks down at peas for the for the
coastal dredging
um quick math at 17.50
and and so that's what we're talking
about is 17 I'm sorry follow-up sorry
follow-up thank you
um
so that's 1750
would have to come from
some other source in order to go into
those pools that you're talking about
those different organizations
or we lose a portion of that 1.75 is
that and the total amount of money that
those 1750 that we
we collect from all boat fees I'm I'm
looking over you you must have the
number there there's a the total amount
of money other than the 1750 per boat
What's the total amount that we're
Distributing
you'd multiply that times the number of
votes we register each year and so it's
approximately a hundred thousand
hundred thousand votes I think a year
correct give or take five or six
depending upon the year okay
now I I will add one more thing in the
defense of the folks from peas
the person who is boating on the
Seacoast must identify at the time of
their registration that they are a
Seacoast voter for that two dollars to
be collected and and unfortunately a lot
of boaters don't do that and therefore
uh to say they're getting two hundred
thousand dollars a year is not the case
so there are others those that's getting
into the weeds but those are some of the
Finer Things that hopefully this study
commission will look at
last question last question is there
another committee that could do this
um I I don't know the answer to that
question sir
um maybe some of your peers might might
have an answer to that the issue at hand
is where you have multiple agents one
one agency collecting multiple agencies
benefiting and now we're being told by
the Coast Guard those multiple agencies
can't be funded by that one boat
registration process
some states are using a secondary decal
program
where they have a decal you you have to
purchase for 17.50 let's say and then
those funds are dispersed but it it's
now an Administration expense decal
expense another agency the voters
getting hit for a second transaction
it's it's
a dilemma
any other questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you so much thank
you all for your questions
with that I have no other pink cards for
this particular
bill so I'm going to close to close the
hearing on HP 137
uh right now our next bill Herring is at
one o'clock so we'll take a lunch and
carrying on hb22 they're required to use
seat belts during the operation of a
motor vehicle in the chair light to call
up a representative recognize
representative vayu
[Music]
thank you Mr chairman members of the
House Transportation committee for the
record my name is representative Dan
vayu I represent Hillsboro 34 in Amherst
I'm here to introduce hb22 I am fully
aware that I'm not the first to
introduce this type of Bill I'm also
well aware of the history of these bills
um I completely understand that New
Hampshire values personal Liberty and
that the absence of a mandatory seat
belt law is a badge of honor and the
Live Free or Die state
we also put a lot of value in personal
responsibility where we accept the
consequences of our actions
much of our philosophy of personal
freedoms based on John Stuart Mill who
said that we should enact laws only in
respect to those actions of each with
which concern the interest of other
people
but he also said that laws may be
justified to compel an individual to
bear his fair share in the common
defense
or in any other joint work
necessary to the interests of society
of which he enjoys the protection and
that a person may cause evil to others
not only by his actions but by his
inaction
and that in either case he is justly
accountable to them for injury
failing to wear a seat belt only works
as an individual for individual freedom
or victimless crime
if it does not if it does no harm to
others and the individual Bears entirely
the responsibility for the consequences
of their actions or in action
willful failure to properly use
passenger restraints when they're
available is not a victimless crime
in the event of a crash any unsecured
object including a human body can become
a projectile causing injury to others in
the vehicle
at 30 miles an hour an unrestrained
passenger weighing 150 pounds exerts the
force of more than two tons 4 500 pounds
as it crashes against another object
including other passengers
when a passenger behind the driver is
unrestrained the odds of a belt
restrained driver sustaining a fatal
injury was increased by 137 percent
when the passenger behind the driver was
unbelted the likelihood of the driver
fatality due to an unrestrained rear
left passenger increased further
119 to 197 percent in the presence of an
additional unrestrained passenger
in the middle of right seats
the risk to other vehicle occupants is
also significantly increased not just
the driver
imagine you the damage you could do to a
child or another adult simply by Falling
on them now imagine following on them at
30 miles an hour
who's going to be in that seat when you
hit them is it going to be a grandchild
a child
a spouse
what kind of damage you're going to do
when you hit them
unrestrained occupants are also 30 times
more likely to be ejected from the
vehicle
one percent of restrained occupants are
ejected compared to almost a third of
unrestrained documents
once ejected almost 80 percent
die as a result
there's also a likelihood that a person
ejected from a vehicle will land on the
roadway where they'll become just
another piece of road debris
that other drivers will attempt to avoid
often unsuccessfully possibly causing a
secondary crash and more damage injuries
or fatalities
one person neglecting to wear a seat
belt increases the likelihood that
others in the vehicle will neglect to
wear theirs as well putting everyone at
risk
if we assume that the unrestrained
vehicle occupants accept full
responsibility for the consequences
then we must assume that they will bear
the burden of the medical expenses for
the injuries
they cause they will bear the cost of
supporting the families of those killed
or permanently disabled
their surviving families will bear the
burden of Long-Term Care Nursing Care
and nursing care for those who survive
but whose injuries render them unable to
care for themselves
we talk about debt but we don't always
talk about the injuries
you're far more likely to be injured
often seriously
and often with permanent lifelong
disabilities or pain
you must also assume that they will
reimburse the First Responders and
medical personnel of whom they enjoyed
and expect the protection
who will be charged with making every
effort to save their life
heal their injuries or clean up their
remains
we often talk about having clear
evidence that something is effective
before acting
seat belts work there is no statistical
twist
I offer one statistic that should be
persuasive to everyone
the national usage rate for seat belts
is 90.4 percent
but 50 of deaths are to those who are
unrestrained
so of the 9.6 percent of people who
drive without seat belts
they account for almost half or over
half of the deaths in this country not
not including the injuries that go along
in New Hampshire the usage rate is only
about 75 percent and it's been creeping
up
only recently
imagine how many deaths
account come along with that extra 15 we
had just been up to the national average
as Dan Goodman AAA pointed on prior
testimony usage is depending on a
three-legged stool of Education
engineering and enforcement
auto manufacturers have done their part
in engineering safer vehicles
by making seat belts more comfortable
and less restrictive installing
persistent reminder Chimes that never
time out
designing safer passenger compartments
and even going so far as to design dual
stage airbags to account for the impact
of unrestrained passengers occupants
the office of Highway Safety spends a
lot of time and money on education
they purchase ads and sponsor events but
research has shown that marketing
doesn't work
I sent you all a paper by Paul slope Dr
Paul slovick one of the top researchers
on risk perception and decision making
if you've read a book on leadership or
decision making you probably heard his
name referenced
he's internationally known and very
renowned in his profession
with all the marketing skills of
professional advertisers and the
knowledge and skill of renowned Scholars
the most creative and scientifically
designed marketing campaigns weren't
successful in persuading people to wear
seat belts which led directly in the
1980s the implementation of mandatory
seatbelt laws literally everywhere in
the country
the burden of convincing people to use
seat belts lies on with law enforcement
they're forced to do marketing campaigns
if they know what are ineffective they
cajole they plead and it's simply
scientifically unrealistic to expect
them to make the kind of progress we
need to make
and 40 Years of effort New Hampshire has
only recently achieved 75 usage rate
when much of the country is already over
90 percent and has been there for quite
some time
that is costing lives
this bill provides the Third Leg of the
stool by providing a very limited
enforcement mechanism it's a secondary
law which means you can't be pulled over
simply for not wearing a seat belt it
it's likely that New Hampshire's
progress increasing seat belt usage is
more a factor of enforcement efforts in
the other 49 states
the message that we send by not having a
law is that it's okay to not wear a
seatbelt in New Hampshire
I'm certain there are people who come
into the state in the immediately click
the release on their seat belt as soon
as they hit the state line
putting themselves and others at risk
obviously we can't get to everyone we
can't get everyone to obey the law
especially if they disagree with it
but at least we can send a consistent
message the seat belts work and we would
that concludes my testimony my
introduction
be glad to understand any questions
thank you any questions from the
committee
thank you very much Mr chair and your
time about the marketing program I know
at past debates in this issue I've been
here 13 years and we've heard similar
bills for Florence
um
and but um which does not say this one
isn't timely but um oh we should do the
marketing are those it's a marketing
campaign and strength and passing this
law are those in any way inconsistent or
mutually exclusive or could we do both
at the same time I think it's important
to do both at the same time
um
enforcement
any of the three legs alone won't be
completely effective I think you have to
have an enforcement mechanism to
any other questions from the committee
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question
I'm I'm curious about
um why you on on page uh two I guess
um line
19 why you left in the uh the person
that is a passenger in a motor vehicle
for hire
um
if you believe that uh having someone
sitting in the back seat
can become the missile why why would you
leave that there and and have them
become that missile
in putting this together I researched a
lot of other state laws and that was a
consistent element in almost all of them
and I think it's because the
responsibility would then fall on the
the company that owns the vehicle to try
to persuade people and
um I think that it would be difficult to
enforce that on people I don't think
it's a statement that it's a wrong thing
to do but I think it's just a
recognition that an Uber driver or a
taxi driver is not going to always be
persuasive if people don't want to
buckle up and they shouldn't be
penalized for it
follow up thank you Mr chairman
um I'm also curious why you believe that
people that cross the border into New
Hampshire
um immediately
disconnect their seatbelt
it's based on conversations that I've
had with State Police officials
um
also posts that I've seen in tourist
sites on Facebook people saying New
Hampshire does it right I was able to
drive in and took off my seat belt and
it was such a relief to be in a state
that has this kind of freedom to me
that's
you know kind of
the wrong message we want to send and
that's why I said that in my my
presentation
representative sellers
I thank you Mr chair so you're saying
freedom is the wrong message we want to
send
no we want to have freedom but we want
to make people accountable for their
decisions and accountable for their
ideas and we want to send a consistent
message that we we hold people
accountable for their
for things that that have effects on
others that your right to Freedom ends
at the tip of my nose
and that you not wearing a sequel is not
a reckless crime that it does affect
others and it is consequential and we
should have an interest in enforcing
that kind of a
policy
any other questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you and if you give
a chance if you can fill the pink card
for me I'd appreciate it
chair now like to recognize
representative Suzanne Vale
who supports the bill
good afternoon thank you Mr chair
thank you honorable members of the
transportation committee
um
I'm a former member of this committee
and um
and a former co-sponsor of this bill and
a co-sponsor once again today
um so I find myself here before you to
reiterate what I've said in the past and
that I find that when you prepare
yourself and your child for travel by
wearing your own seat belt and by
wearing by using appropriate restraints
in your vehicle you have the best chance
of survival on New Hampshire highways in
today you'll hear countless statistics
that show that seat belts save lives
they save quality of life and they
reduce trauma to individuals involved in
an accident the degree of human
suffering can be sharply reduced and
that's why we are asking people to wear
these seat belts my concerns and my
support from the bill comes from my
recognition that our personal choices
affect more than just our own personal
lives they affect law enforcement and
all emergency responders that arrive out
of motor vehicle accident
responders in New Hampshire must face
exacerbated and extended consequences of
their time on the road responding
responding to motor vehicle casualties
and we're not just talking about
statistics we're talking about we're not
just talking about cost and we're really
not talking about any one aspect of what
happens when people don't wear a
seatbelt and they're involved in a motor
what is an overwhelming amount of
evidence that we need to protect
citizens by making seat belt use
mandatory has not been persuasive in the
past but it should be today with the
exception supplied in the bill to use
safety equipment that's already in your
car and must be in working condition in
order for it to pass inspection
with that I will conclude my testimony
however brief it might be I just want to
get the point across that the human
suffering that's caused by not wearing
seat belts
may be a cost that we cannot really
recognize as a true cost but it really
does have a dollar value and this is a
really important bill to get our state
in line with other states where safety
is a priority thank you so much and I'll
be happy to take your questions
thank you so much any questions from the
committee
not seeing any thank you
recognizes Chris uh Vetter from the
office of Highway Safety
asking for five minutes and he supports
testimony
foreign
they explain themselves uh thank you for
the for the opportunity I appreciate the
committee uh allowing me to come in and
speak
um my name is Chris Fetter I work for
the state police I've been a trooper for
31 years and today I recognize I
represent rather the office of Highway
Safety many of whom are sitting behind
me
um our mission at the office of Highway
Safety is to reduce crashes and to
eliminate fatalities we do this through
a variety of ways to include funding
educational and enforcement activities
all designed with this mission in mind
the office of Highway Safety sees this
pending legislation at the top of our
list the priorities to help accomplish
our goal
and I am proud to represent our office
before this committee
my testimony will revolve around facts
data and personal experiences as a
31-year trooper regarding seat belt
usage in New Hampshire in the hopes of
assisting this committee and hopefully
the legislature and the decision making
on this legislation
this is a fact New Hampshire is the only
state in the nation
without a mandatory seat belt law for
people over the age of 18.
what I have come to learn in my two
years in the office of Highway Safety is
that there is a belief amongst many
within the state of New Hampshire
that we can accomplish the voluntary use
of seat belts through education and
Outreach
data suggests that that belief is
inaccurate
the national highway traffic safety
administration funds visual seat belt
use surveys in all 50 states on a yearly
basis
the study done in 2021 shows 27 states
have seatbelt use rates above 90 percent
44 states are above 80 percent
of the 50 states in the nation New
Hampshire is dead last at 75.5
one in four individuals observed driving
on the roads of New Hampshire do so
unrestrained
to put that into perspective
think of this fact in the following
terms the next time the entire New
Hampshire House of Representatives
gathers and representatives Hall
all 400 or so strong
look around the room and consider that
100 of your colleagues will drive
unrestrained when they head home that
day
there is also a belief but that those
who choose not to utilize the seat belt
commit a victimless crime representative
made mention to this that harms only
themselves
on this past Thanksgiving morning a
single vehicle rollover crash occurred
in the city of Portsmouth
of the six young adults inside the
vehicle the driver was properly
restrained and suffered minor injury
the four individuals in the back seat
were unrestrained
all four were ejected
suffered significant traumatic injuries
and one of the individuals lost her life
I could say with first-hand knowledge
that there are many victims of this
crash
First Responders trying valiantly to
save the lives of those ejected
family members that were told that their
loved one loved ones were badly injured
some suffering injuries so severe that
they are likely life-altering one family
was told that their loved one had not
survived that crash
I will conclude my testimony with a
personal experience regarding the use of
seat belts in January 2016 a college
student was returning from dinner to
campus at Franklin Pierce University in
Rindge
as he rounded a corner on Route 202 in
Peterborough the driver noticed a
vehicle coming at him head on in his
Lane and at a high rate of speed
the young man driving took evasive
action however he was unable to avoid a
collision
the speeding vehicle struck him in the
area of the driver's side front wheel
at what would later be determined by the
New Hampshire state police car unit as
88 miles an hour
the victim's vehicle went into a spin
and he rolled several times coming to
rest on its roof in the middle of route
202.
this young man who was wearing a seat
belt lost Consciousness as a result of
the impact and when emergency Personnel
arrived he was found hanging upside down
suspended in his seat belt
First Responders would later tell me
that this young man would clearly have
suffered significant injury and likely
would have been ejected had he not worn
his seatbelt in all likelihood the seat
belt saved his life
as the offending driver went off to New
Hampshire State Prison to serve his
three to five year sentence the young
man who was the victim
went on to complete his degree at
Franklin Pierce within 12 hours of
completing his last class there he was
sworn in as a New Hampshire state
trooper
where he is now four and a half years
into a successful career
I'm proud to tell you that that Trooper
seat belts are the single best way to
avoid injury or death should you be
involved in a motor vehicle crash that
is a fact
I'd like to thank the committee for
their time and I'm happy to answer any
questions that you might have
thank you so much any
questions from the committee
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question can you explain the primary and
secondary on your colorful chart
primary seat belt law is essentially
what representative vayu said primary
seat belt law can be enforced without
any other motor vehicle violations
whereas a secondary seat belt law can be
enforced once uh the car has been
stopped for something else whether it be
speed or any other type of motor vehicle
violence thank you
any other questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you so much thank
you
chair now recognizes Neil Moore
from Parkland Medical Center
who supports the bill in looking for
good afternoon everybody uh so as he as
he noted my name is Neil Moore so I'm a
trauma nurse I work at Parkland Medical
Center in Derry
I've been a nurse for 29 years 18 years
of those have been around trauma
I am also a father of two teens I have
two daughters one daughter who started
driving last year another daughter who
started driving this year
and so I'm very invested in this bill
I've been at Parkland for six years I
also serve as the vice chair for the
trauma medical Review Committee here at
New Hampshire
I'm also on that committee under Trauma
Nurse representative for the state so
I have the honor of representing all the
nurses in the state regarding trauma so
I just have a couple of patients that I
can talk to you about just this year at
Parkland
uh recently with all the icy conditions
we've had we saw a family of four
um both the driver and the passenger in
the front were restrained that two kids
in the back were also restrained and
they lost control on the highway High
rate of speed they rolled multiple times
and they were all able to self-extricate
they all came to Parkland
um none of them had any major injuries
they were all discharged home
also this year we had a individual who
his car impacted with a pole he was not
restrained
uh his his airbag did deploy but his
head went through the windshield uh he
was asystolic on this team which means
that he basically his heart was not not
beaded on the scene EMS did resuscitate
or attempt to resuscitate they were not
able to get him back when he got to us
he still had no heartbeat we worked him
up briefly and he died in the ER
um and then just today there's this
morning
as you guys are aware we've we had a lot
of icy conditions this morning we had
quite a few uh car crashes that came
into the ER
a couple of those patients were also
involved in rollovers they were all
restrained they were all worked up they
were all discharged home
um
let me just see I've also done a PSA on
teen safety recently just talking about
seat belt use
uh one thing I know from going with my
kids with their education so they are
educated as teenagers to wear seat belts
they see all the videos they know the
dangers and they're also aware that in
New Hampshire at the age of 18 they
could remove those seat belts and as the
trooper mentioned behind us so the
accident Portsmouth there were
individuals there who were in their
early twenties who'd all gone through
that training and they did remove their
seat belts so
we do need more incentive to get people
to wear their seat belts it does save
lives
and that's my testimony if you guys have
any questions thank you so much any
questions from the committee
not seeing any thank you so much thank
you
chair now like to recognize Gary Woods
for nhms
who supports the bill and is seeking
uh thank you Mr chair and thank you
committee for having this hearing
um
I um
nhms's New Hampshire Medical Society for
those who may not know the anachronym
um my name is Gary Woods
I'm in strong support of House Bill 222
from a variety of venues first of all I
understand the basic science behind it
as I was originally a physicist through
graduate school before I went to medical
school
um
became an orthopedic surgeon
and unfortunately
with the recipient sometimes two and
three in the morning of the people
you've heard talked about it was up to
us to
to put the pieces back together if we
possibly could
um I kind of give a little bit of my own
history which gives give you an idea of
why I'm here but also a little bit of
why we're all here uh first of all a
hundred years or 50 years ago we didn't
have cars so this would have been a
non-issue obviously
um
I have long contact with the safety belt
issue
again from the basic science perspective
but the medical perspective both through
the emergency room but also the
follow-up care which you've heard
mentioned
um
first of all I was in practice started
in 76 my first office partner with a MIT
trained engineer he was a senior faculty
member and we ran an 80 bed Orthopedic
award at the teaching Hospital
um
he did the engineering work initially
for safety builds or General Motors and
Ford was under contract and published
the scientific data but showed the
efficacy of safety builds
as a consequence he sought to have a
legislation for New York which was
passed the first in the nation
the state of New of New York awarded him
the Excalibur award
for the service to the people and
citizens of of New York it's the highest
award you can give a in a private
citizen
it's that contact both in the basic
science and the educational and
legislative part that I moved here in
1982 to continue that work I got a grant
from the motor vehicle manufacturers
Association where they gave Monies to
each state I ran that for five or six
years but they realized that wait a
minute
as you heard New Hampshire is the only
state that doesn't have legislation for
adult
safety belts they said we've done our
job since there's only one state left we
lost our money and now we've been trying
so it's with that background that I
approached this problem
but I'd like to skip some of the data
you've heard that and you'll probably
hear more of it but instead I'd like to
focus on two issues the petitional
potential negative effects of safety
belts and how safety belts are an
effective preventive measure
negative effects
in Nash in in New Hampshire we're
oftentimes very much made aware uh that
one of the most visible was a newspaper
publisher at the union leader Naki Loeb
was involved in a vehicle accident and
it was clearly stated that had she been
wearing a safety belt she would be dead
and indeed that's true
the reason was
she was a passenger and a post-world War
II Jeep vehicle now you remember what
they look like other than
the little windshield that comes up on a
hinge there's nothing above your seat
in a rollover she was indeed saved
because she was thrown free had she been
a safety belt and that she would have
been crushed
but that's
not the vehicles we drive today
they're very much different
the work that was done by Dr States as I
mentioned
and the industry itself took the
initiative to put in measures so that
they're easily available easily used and
very efficacious
did you do have a minor
negative effect nothing's perfect
even the best medication has some side
effects
not using safety belts
because there's a small
percent
then it might be dangerous
can because first of all you might not
be using it properly and that's where
the vast majority of belt injuries come
from from misuse
but the perspective of just not using it
would be like if you're a skier and most
of us are here in New Hampshire
there's a small a percent even if you do
the best you can to get your skis and
your your bindings everything fit just
right
there's a small percent that they're
going to release early and cause you
major injury
you don't want to take a small percent
chance you don't want that to happen so
to avoid that small percent
chance
you're going to bolt your bolts to your
skis
they won't release early that way you've
avoided that very small percent but
you've exposed yourself to horrific
consequences
we also hear as the topics being brought
infringing on our personal freedoms it
is a negative effect
that one must ask whose freedom
and you've heard allusion to the
consequences
not only for the person who sustains the
injury but the families
for the employer he has to if you're out
of work
disrupts production disrupts him so
there's the consequences that you see
after that
and also if you have long-term
difficulties you expect
your neighbor
me to take care of you
right
now let me ask you
if you really said I really have to have
my freedoms
and I will I'm as a consequence I'm
willing to sign a waiver
that if I need long-term care because
I'm a quad
and costing a million dollars a year
uh for the state to take care of me
no you don't have to do that because
what you're asking you want your
freedoms
but I have no freedom I have to pay
taxes
to take care of you
we have to go back on what is the common
good you do what you can if you've done
what you can
I'm more than happy to participate at
two or three in the morning even if you
don't have insurance
first of all you've heard that you have
better control of your car and I won't
go through all of that
there's much diminished extent of direct
injury being ejected or indirectly
um
that won't go over all that you've heard
that story and it's somewhat obvious
anyway
in closing what I would like to do
is to ask you a question
I'm a physician
although I'm retired I'm a physician and
and it said it would save say well on
average 13 lives a year and Untold
injuries
but only I could sign it
what would you think if I put that
prescription in my pocket
and walked out
leaving 13 to 15 people dead
how do you think that would go with the
public
Board of Medicine
I have such a prescription
you can
you can sign the prescription
that saves lives
and prevents injuries and it says right
here
signed New Hampshire legislator and I
leave that with you
thank you
thank you so much any questions from the
committee
representative Sinclair
thank you Mr chair and thank you
it seems like you've done a lot of work
from what I've just heard in your
testimony up with the manufacturers uh
over your the course of your career has
there been any encouragement from your
group or other groups for the public
safety tool to get the manufacturers uh
to make the vehicles unable to start
until the belt is engaged like they've
got the technology now to make it so I
can't put my car in gear without tapping
the brake first so as an example
the answer is yes there were that was
considered way back probably I'm taking
a guess here probably mid 90s is that
far back that was considered
um and it was elected not to do that for
a variety of reasons
a quick follow-up follow-up
would you maybe in light of all the
testimony here and even with these
figures maybe give a push again for that
I would certainly entertain that uh yeah
that's sort of a sidebar uh it does it
has a tendency in getting going down
that rabbit hole what we have currently
in place is free
easy to use and we know is just
immensely successful
thank you and trying to go even that
step further would might negate that
progress
any further questions from the committee
chair now like to recognize Roger
Richard who's representing himself
hello I'd like to thank everybody for
have being here today
um yes I opposed A bill my name is Roger
Richard I'm 60 years old native of New
Hampshire born in Manchester Notre Dame
Hospital
I had never worn a seatbelt in my own
personal vehicle
been driving the roads for 45 years
I did wear a seat belt for 33 years at
my job I was a mailman I had to or I was
going to get fired or if I got in an
accident I could not get my bills paid
so I made a choice
stay at the post office because a
long-term benefit that time was good for
myself
I could have left I could have made a
choice
there are people behind me that are in
organizations that can also make the
choice when they say oh I see people
this way that way mangled you have the
choice
we are guaranteed oh excuse me I was I
was also called In This Very building
over 30 years ago a child hater because
I opposed the children's seat belt not
because I hate children because it's
called incrementalism
it went from age they told me oh you're
just too you think way too much went
from 6 12 18 and you've been knocking on
my door ever since shame on this it's
really wrong to tell people we only
worry about the children and then try to
back door you it's not good okay it's
not good for a native of New Hampshire
to be backdoored
I've been in New Hampshire for 56 out of
the 60 years I was in the Army for four
years defending our Liberty our New
Hampshire way of life
I don't want to give it up
if you want to wear a seatbelt please do
it you have it don't make me I've heard
all kinds of stuff here about
accountability well I am accountable I
have been accountable and I make my
children accountable I'm trying to make
um talking about oh the taxes the taxes
of the people that get an accident
without without these seat belt well
people get in accidents with seat belts
and without seat belts and the cost is
pretty much the same hospitals are
outrageous now the taxes we have
141 people I believe last year dinar and
our our highways
40 000 in the highways Across the Nation
141 without a seat belt and still close
to 40 000 had died with seat belts
I don't see the scale
the taxation part again
um
I have noticed for years and years and
years we have a drug epidemic that's
costing us all all
okay a lot of money Narcan
housing you name it everything because
we create it and I mean we and I'm gonna
specifically say
doctors were involved in the creation of
it so when a doctor talks to me about
saving money on taxes think about what
you created first they gave drugs away
like they're going out of style now I
have to pay and now you want me to take
my my Liberty and just give it up
because of payment it doesn't make sense
to me the scales aren't there again
um the Constitution the reason why I am
so adamant I my principles have not
changed
I believe in the Constitution I believe
I defended it I took an oath just like
every one of you took an oath uphold the
Constitution against enemies foreign and
domestic
I believe anyone that goes after the
Constitution is an enemy I don't care
where they're from
Constitution covers all of us equally
and it doesn't matter your race your
color your Creed anything
foreign
state constitution guarantees me
unalienable right of Liberty
I looked it up in the dictionary Liberty
is the right to choose
I have that right to choose
now article 3 of our state constitution
in the parentheses and I I'm not going
to pull it up okay I'm going to give it
to you paraphrase that might be a word
or two off please correct me and I will
accept whatever you say on it
it's about Society
organization and purpose
we're all in a society here
when men enter into a state of society
they surrender up some of their natural
rights to ensure the protection of
others if the law is not as equivalent
the surrender is void 1784.
now let me give a little for people that
might not have understood what I said
when men enter and when men enter into a
state of society we surrender up some of
our natural rights I told you my natural
right is Liberty do I Surrender up my
Liberty my choice to choose I don't
think I Surrender it's unalienable
they surrender map to ensure the
protection of others wait a minute my
Liberty of freedom of speech and a movie
theater is suspended because others are
involved because if I yell fire
Stampede people are dead
me in my vehicle by myself we're not
wearing a seat belt is me
not anybody else I've heard projectiles
and again I've been to every single
meeting except for one because my
grandchild was in surgery since it
started
um
I lost my track
the accountability part
icle 4 of our constitution guarantees us
a conscience
I have automobile insurance never went
without it I have health insurance never
went without it I have disability
insurance never went without it I've got
jobs and held jobs with sick leave and
vacation time and different things
I've been accountable
and I don't think I need to take the hit
because I'm accountable and I'm also
teaching other people how to be
accountable we should not have to take a
hit on our Liberty Liberty because
somebody thinks whoa I I saw this I saw
that these people are mangled yes it
happens people can make on bicycles fall
off horses die
airbags airbags are in automobiles
airbags
are not reliable
companies are going out of business
worldwide because they're airbags are
defective
seat belts number one thing I believe
seat belts cause in an accident is a
dissection of the Carotid artery because
it grabs you right there and the first
thing they do is they look at you and
they look to see if your pupils are
dilated because it's called Horner
syndrome
one of the number one things so wearing
a seat belt could injure me or it could
not injure me wearing a seatbelt or not
wearing a seatbelt I believe I have the
same faith
it doesn't matter to me again 45 years
legally in New Hampshire I'm still here
not that I'm I'm boasting about it but
it doesn't happen to everybody and
everybody should not have to take the
it's also been said marketing didn't
work
well why do I still hear my tax money
going into the radio waves about oh
buckle up your kids oh they sound like
wolves make them sound like wolves the
kids are bad why do we do that if it's
not working why are we making our kids
sound bad we've already buckled them up
they're supposed to be good
I I don't think I have any more to say I
thank you very much for your time and um
I oppose this and for our constitution
thank you so much
no I thank you Mr chair representative I
take it you'd like to follow the
Constitution very closely I tried my
best
thank you oh I'm sorry any other
questions
representative Sinclair thank you
so you don't wear one because you don't
like being told what to do or okay or
let me say so or is it because they're
uncomfortable uncomfortable and that
would if I did start wearing it I'd be
violating another law that you people
passed would be the distraction law
I feel comfortable not wearing it I'm
not distracted if I'm wearing it I'm
distracted I'm always I'd be violating
another loss so which way do I go again
thank you yes thank you
any other questions
not seeing any thank you thank you very
much
okay chair now I'd like to recognize Dan
Goodman from AAA
who supports the bill and also has some
written testimony
thank you very much and for the record
my name is Dan Goodman and I'm the
public affairs manager for AAA Northern
New England and I'm here in support of
the bill
um
it's it I'll try not to repeat some of
the the facts and figures that have been
mentioned before
um the simplest
and most cost-effective way that we can
reduce injuries deaths and Associated
economic costs on New Hampshire highways
today is by buckling up your safety belt
in the most recent study survey that is
out there
they say that seat belts across the
country saved almost 15 000 lives
it's estimated if New Hampshire had a
seat belt lock today
that we would save lives serious
injuries and up to 22 million dollars in
Associated costs
and part of that is due to
that inpatient costs for unbelted crash
victims are 55 percent higher than
belted crash victims
according to the most recent studies if
you buckle up in the front seat of your
your car you reduce the injury of a
fatal injury by 45 percent
and moderate to your critical injury by
um we
it this might make some members happy or
we did our first or we recently did a
survey of AAA members and non-members
across the state of New Hampshire
to see if they supported a seat belt law
it was and 91 percent
support of seat belt law
so today this is a bill that if it
passes will save lives decrease injuries
and lower the associated social costs
associated with a crash this is
supported across the state Across the
Nation
and as was mentioned I'll repeat it
because it's it's for us who are in this
field that's an alarming
thing to say but New Hampshire is the
only state
the only state without a seat belt law
consequently we have the lowest safety
belt use in the country
and the highest unbelted fatality rate
at 58 percent
I don't know what the other states off
top my head around
us do but I do know that I believe
Vermont is 38 percent
so 38 percent of their fatalities are
unbelted and we are over half it's a
it's a very Stark difference
um and
and I get oh the last thing I'll say in
on the back of my chart I uh include
some statistics on you know what the
seat belt uses in our in our compared to
the states around us as was mentioned
the national average is the
Captain better may have had more
up-to-date data I had 20 21 data
um so it was 91.6 was the national
average Vermont at 89.2 percent in Maine
at 91.8 percent
and you can see our unbelted fatality
rate over the last five years
um it is improving but it's still I
think unacceptable as we've we've talked
on multiple highway safety issues one
victim one fatality is just too many
um
you know safety belts are designed to
help the motorists maintain position
behind the wheel to better control the
vehicle during a skidder Collision
safety belt become standard because they
help ride down the force of a crash and
reduce the impact between the occupant
and the vehicle interior interior safety
belt significantly reduced injury the
risk excuse me of being thrown from a
vehicle
and with that that's uh my testimony I'm
thank you so much
representative Crawford
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question do you um could you
give us the number of people that you
surveyed in New Hampshire do you have
that number
um you said 91 of your survey
um agreed to for seat belts for New
Hampshire but how many people did you
survey do you know I will I will email
you that
um they just told me when I when I asked
the statisticians
um in our department I uh they just told
me it was statistically significant
because I asked how well does this
represent AAA members which is 520 530
000 members in the state of New
Hampshire and our population and they
just told me it statistically
significant but I'll follow up I didn't
ask exactly how many but I will get you
that information thank you for the
question
representative Sinclair thank you and
nice to see you again
you get the data here in your handout it
says lack of safety belts drugged and
distracted driving and speeding are
those
all the same line like with unseated or
unbelted people no no no those are just
the top reasons independent and many of
in many of those happen at the same time
but that they're independent they are
just the top reasons we are seeing an
increase in fatalities in this state
follow up thank you for the question I
apologize thank you and
um I I had asked I want to have this on
the record because I know we talked
about this before but has has AAA
encouraged manufacturers to do their
part to make it
um technical that make it technically
impossible to start your vehicle without
the uh belts being
engaged through make up for all the
people who are not doing it
thank you for the question I'm unaware
if we've ever engaged in manufacturers
to have that discussion
um it was interesting to hear with Dr
Woods please said about that but it's
something I I think it's a it's a good
conversation to to continue I I'd like
to as a triple A Member I hope you do
that thank you thank you for the
question representative sellers
thank you Mr chair
so on your second paragraph here you
have especially in bold print it says
according to a 22 2023 survey of AAA
members and non-members of New Hampshire
all right so our the AAA members all of
New Hampshire residents
this was a survey that was only for AAA
members and now so it was only for New
Hampshire yes follow-up
follow-up
my second question is
you're here representing AAA why are you
actually putting in non AAA members I'm
a triple A Member and I'm just wondering
to me are you representing Triple A or
are you
representing AAA and others
thank you thank you for the question I I
do work for AAA in representing Triple A
um I will
as a follow-up to representative
Crawford as well I'll follow up with the
the statisticians to figure out to
determine why they chose to include
members and AAA members in the same
survey
does that is that acceptable yeah I
think it would I think it would clear up
your numbers thank you
any other questions from the committee
representative Horrigan
thank you I too am a triple A Member and
I have a marketing degree my guess is
going to be is that uh
um is that probably you just took a
survey you hired somebody to do a survey
of drivers many of whom are AAA members
so that was probably you were probably
actually sampling drivers some of whom
are many of whom are AAA members and
some of whom aren't many who aren't but
my question is the unbuilted fatality
rate what are you dividing by what since
I assume um
I assume probably there's lots of car
accidents where no one is killed like in
probably some of those people are
unbelted so what exactly what exactly is
it you're a dividing what by what to get
that 58 percent
thank you for the question
um this data comes from the state and my
assumption is and uh feel for the office
of Highway Safety uh feel free to
correct me here but I believe it's they
look at the number of fatalities and
then they determine how many then you
know in those police reports you can
determine if they're wearing their seat
belt if they weren't wearing their seat
belt so it's the number of fatalities
where they were not wearing a seat belt
and so it's the percentage of that total
that sounds plausible to me I'm going to
infer for example that about 60 of the
people who die in car crashes aren't
belted even though only 25 percent of
them are in fact unbelted according to
the other numbers we have okay thanks
any other questions from the committee
representative
wondering how many uh fatalities there
are wearing belts
thank you for the question
again I I if I'm wrong in explaining
this data highway safety please jump in
here or clarify this after my testimony
but I would assume it is
so if in 2022 the unbeltailed fatality
rate is 50 58 I don't know if it would
exactly be 42 percent I know that maybe
some the it's an unknown that's my
assumption I I I don't know if that's a
fact but it could be as high as 42
percent for the most recent I would just
think it's the you know you want to get
to 100 so it's
you subtract 58 from 100 and you get 42.
thank you
any other questions
not seeing any thank you so much thank
you
chair do I like to recognize Eric Martin
from New Hampshire cot
who supports the bill who is asking for
three minutes
thank you this is on correct
um so thank you for allowing me to speak
I have been here on two previous
opportunities to speak in support of
similar bills and I'm here again today
as you mentioned to speak in support of
House Bill 222 as a point of background
I'm a trauma surgeon at Dartmouth
Hitchcock I've been there going on 12
years currently I'm the trauma medical
director at that institution I share the
role of chair and co-chair I'm the chair
of the New Hampshire trauma medical
Review Committee I'm the chair of the
New Hampshire chapter of the committee
on trauma which is an organization of
I have not I was not you know I'm not a
native born New Hampshire person I get
that but uh for point of reference I
spent five years in the Marine Corps
serving our country for the same rights
as everybody else so I do choose to live
in New Hampshire I've been here seven
years 17 years and I I have no plans on
leaving and I hope to retire here
um so I'm here representing myself as a
citizen as well as a trauma surgeon and
the co team membership
I last spoke here five years ago and I
know that because I look back at my my
notes and there was a my testimony there
where I shared a story of two young men
who died it was very emotional still is
um but I felt like trying to share that
story again is going to be the loss
because
we hear about all these reasons as to
why we don't need seat belts because
it's a personal choice I think these two
young men died in their 20s probably
because when I was in my 20s I did a lot
of silly things too but overall I was
trying to follow the laws and try to do
the right thing but you kind of need
those guidances those moments to allow
you to live long enough to learn the
responsible choices that are required to
to become a you know a member of society
and a contributing member of society
both of their lives were cut short so as
as much as it is hard to talk about that
story I thought I would talk about some
data and I got this data from the New
Hampshire office of Highway Safety it
was shared with me we talked about a lot
of numbers but to your point of how many
people were died and this has died at
over 2022 or excuse me 2020 to 2022 so a
three-year Collective numbers and this
is New Hampshire data there were 116
vehicle deaths or driver deaths of
people who were unrestrained versus uh
47 deaths for drivers who were
restrained and if you look at the
passenger data there were 30 people
killed who are not wearing their
seatbelts and only 12 killed while
wearing their seatbelts so when I do
that math it equates to being over 50
percent increase in your mortality by
not wearing a seat belt so we've heard
all the benefits we've heard lots of
stories I had many points here that I
was going to use as counter arguments to
all the other arguments that I've heard
in the past
but I don't want to be repetitive or you
know redundant in the things that I've
said there's been pretty good evidence
about the financial costs of shared
amongst all of us I think that's true
I've I've had patients in our
Institution for months you know it's the
deaths in some ways are easier if you're
dead at the scene that is a personal
choice you've died that your family has
to pay the price for that the four-month
child old child of the first individual
that I declared dead that night 11 years
ago he's still paying that price it's
it's the financial burden that is shared
amongst all of us and it's millions of
dollars as was shared these these
individuals may not have insurance they
not may not be as responsible as Mr
Richard in the back and have insurance
and there are many people who are not
held accountable and that cost gets
shared amongst all of us and it's not
just the cost to have them survive it's
the long-term care when they severe you
know severe traumatic brain injuries and
they need full care the rest of their
life and they go on disability so there
are expenses that are shared amongst all
of us for many years that people don't
appreciate
but on my drive here I started thinking
about how can I share the realities of
Our Lives as medical providers and
that's the daily ins and outs and and
Health Care is strained it's been
strained but it's certainly worse now
and Healthcare is triage and triage
starts with the sickest person and no
matter what environment whether you're
in the Ed waiting room or you're at the
scene of an accident so if Mr Richard
crashes into you and a head-on collision
and is ejected from the vehicle he is
much more likely to be severely injured
and you might be driving your car
wearing your seatbelt but you may also
have some critical injuries that may not
be as acutely apparent so the the first
person who's going to go to the hospital
is the one who's more injured so that
might be most likely Mr Richard so
they're right there your your ability to
make a fair and equal Choice was taken
away from you because you don't come to
the game with the same amount of
responsibility you don't come to the
game with the same amount of expected
care because in Northern New Hampshire
there are limited resources limited
pre-hospital providers limited small
hospitals that have understaffed so when
they roll into the hospital everything
stops no matter what hospital you're at
everything stops all the attention goes
to the sickest patient so if your loved
one is there for a heart attack or a
stroke or any other medical problem that
those two nurses and that one provider
in that institution are going to get
shifted and you're going to be left
alone it's a reality of the situation
it's a reality at our institution we're
a busy hospital we say no to people more
now than we ever have so if I have to
say no to Colebrook that means they're
going to have to go four hours by ground
to you know Elliott or Portsmouth or
some other large hospital so all of
these decisions have Downstream effects
that do affect all of us but we didn't
make the wrong choice we made the right
choice we were trying to be responsible
we're trying to wear our seat belts we
try to do the right things but there are
costs to us when other people don't make
that same decision
it reminds me every day
this is important
you know there are four parts to a
trauma system there's the pre-hospital
providers who day and night are out
there risking their lives there's a
hospital that take care of these people
when they arrive there's the rehab part
where people go to to try to get back to
a normal sense of life and be productive
members of society and there's injury
prevention and yeah we do a lot of
education but you've heard how it's
three parts and the one part that we
don't have is the legal part it's a
secondary bill
it's
it's probably as far as a seatbelt bill
goes I think probably the most benign
but it will change it will change lives
and I I when I do the math looking at
these numbers over the five years I
estimate they're probably 50 to 100
deaths that could have been prevented
over the last five years from the time I
last spoke so
I appreciate your time
thank you so much any questions from the
committee representative Sykes
thank you Mr chairman thank you sir for
taking my question you may not be the
right person to ask you but we'll get
started
um
as far as I can tell most of the data
that we've been hearing today is the
numbers of
unvelted versus belted fatalities
do we keep data about belted versus
unbelted
serious injuries
we have a data of who's as far as
injured yes belted and unbalted I think
the data collected of
the severity of those injuries for from
a New Hampshire standpoint would be
difficult because we don't have a good
Collective data repository but I think
National Data will tell you that your
injury severity goes up when you're not
wearing a seatbelt and when you're
injected that's what I'm trying to get
to okay
thank you
any other questions
so with that I have no other pink cards
so at this point I'll end the public
go ahead
that was getting the hot water here is
it possible to ask
the trooper another question that
testified that
sure since if he'd be so kind to come
back
huh
I really appreciate this representative
Sinclair thank you
um
sir I'm just curious here it says here
in in the uh line 16 the position
provisions of this section shall be
enforceable only as a secondary offense
when the police officer detains the
driver for a suspected violation
my question is
if they're not guilty of that suspected
offense
and they did not have their seatbelt on
would they then be able to give a ticket
for the seat belt even though what they
originally start for did not constitute
a violation
I guess that would be an issue for the
courts right so if if there was a
summons issued for whatever the original
violation was that will not mean that he
or she will not have the right to
um could test that charge
and contest the seat belts in the same
direction the same way I think I know
what you're asking but
um no if I what I mean is let's say uh
let's say my car touched the white line
and the officer has probable cause I
think perhaps this person is driving
Under the Influence or something like
that and is finds out that no none of
that applies but I'm not wearing a seat
belt would they then be able to give me
a ticket for the seat belt although I'm
not charged with anything else yes if
they were if the stop was made for a
valid motor vehicle violation
even though there was no motor vehicle
violation at the time other in other
words I wasn't I wasn't drunk I wasn't
driving impaired or anything like that
okay you're good to go but you're not
wearing a seatbelt so now I'm going to
give you a ticket for that right but my
guess is in your scenario the stop
wasn't made because you were drunk the
stop was made because you went over the
white line which is a totally separate
thing so if you're talking about the
violation would still exist you just may
not be impaired in your scenario you
could be stopped for speeding and you
stop for any vote any multitude of
things right and you would have their if
you were found if you were given a
summons or you're arrested for the
original charge you'd have the
opportunity to contest that at any point
in time okay thank you
representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman and this is along those same
lines in in your opinion
um is the bill a weaker bill because it
is uh based on secondary offense rather
I don't know that I don't know that I'm
really in the position states weaker
what I would say is this uh I am for
whatever
uh requires people who wear seatbelts
so if if it's enforceable after a
regular car stop and people will put
them on then
um for that maybe people will put them
on knowing if I get stopped for
something else I'm going to have you
know I'm going to have to deal with the
seat belt issue after I'm for whatever
makes people put seat belts on it this
is not at least I can speak only for
myself this is not an excuse to stop
cars and to write tickets this is about
getting people to wear seat belts
um I've been here 31 years I'm about
making people safe I think my testimony
okay at this point
everybody
foreign
is
yeah
thank you
today
um
all right good
thank you
foreign
up the exact session on House Bill 153
um at this point I'd like to take a
quick recess of about 10 minutes and
then we'll pick up the exact session on
153.
um
captured on
hb153 which is relative to roadway
pedestrian control signals
in the chair like to recognize Alvin C
for a motion
I move on to pass on uh house bill 153.
by representative Saint Claire
also would you like to speak on the
amendment
uh like the move Amendment uh
so the motion on the floor is right now
move to
pass on Amendment
was the number
zero five five two zero five five two
like to take the all those in favor vote
yay
I need a second on the amendment
second by representative Sinclair
so let's take a vote for it and all
those in favor I I imposed
the eyes have it
so the current motion right now is OTP
on HB 153
otpa and 153.
with an amendment
representative C would you like to speak
on
your motion
yes the the amendment uh clarifies the
description that was provided in the
original Bill Without Really changing
anything other than making it a little
bit easier to read the bill
uh
but the the bill itself and this and the
amendment does not change it just uh
clarifies uh two things one along with
the walk and don't walk things uh
signals uh it also includes four symbols
of a walking person or up raised hand
and the other
issue is under the walk signal
um
a person uh
shall not start to uh across the or no
person shall start to cross the roadway
if such Crossing interferes with
vehicular traffic and however any person
who is partially completed Crossing
shall proceeds through safety uh across
okay not seeing any I'll have the clerk
do the role on
OTP a on hb-153
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
Dumas yes representative Boyd yes
representative Wallace yes
representative C yes representative
sellers yes representative Moffett yes
representative Sykes yes representative
uh Celia Rich yes representative
Sinclair yes representative Fox yes
representative Rambo yes representative
vayu yes representative Coker yes
representative Horrigan yes
representative Rich yes representative
move consent move to consent
do we have a second
second by representative domain no
objections
next bill we're going to exact is HB
356.
to Chairman I'd like to make a motion of
itl on 356.
motion is itl on 356.
we have a second representative Hill
representative Crawford would you like
to speak on your motion
I would if I could find my paper
um
the sponsor of the bill came in and
actually requested that we itl this bill
so it's simple we're italing this bill
any other comments on this bill from the
committee
not seeing any I'll let the clerk make
foreign representative Smith yes clerk
votes yes representative Hill yes
representative Dumas yes representative
Boyd yes representative Wallace yes
representative C yes representative
sellers yes representative Moffett yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Sia Rich representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative
yes representative Cocker yes sorry
representative Horrigan yes
representative Rich yes representative
Staub yes and chairman Gorski yes 20 to
zero twenty to zero do we have movements
consent
consent by
representative domain do we have a
second second representative Sinclair
who seconded that representative
representative
Mr chairman I'd like to make motion
wait a second one second please Oh I
chair I'd like to recognize
representative Hill for a motion
uh thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman I'd
like to move uh itl on House Bill 386
do we have a second
by representative Rambo from Rambo
so representative Hill would you like to
speak on your motion briefly it's a very
brief Bill uh it simply moves the age of
the passenger uh from age seven down to
age four
um for child safety seats
um
I've never liked anything that had to do
with safety seats that dealt with ages
where children at that age or those ages
are all over the place as far as height
and weight that seems to be making more
sense but I don't see anything in the
bill
that we should be concerned about for
itlings so I would suggest that be the
motion
any other comments from the committee
not seeing any I'll let the clerk make
the roll call and the current motion on
representative Smith yes
clerk votes yes representative Hill
yes representative Dumas yes
representative Boyd yes representative
Wallace yes representative C yes
representative sellers
now
representative
um Moffett
yes
representative Sykes
representative Celia Rich yes
representative Sinclair yes
representative Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative Ayu yes
representative Coker yes representative
Horrigan
yes representative Rich yes
representative Staub yes Gorski chairman
Gorski yes
representative KO could we have a second
so that's all we're going to be at
that's going to finalize our exec
session for today uh quick housekeeping
item
uh the only thing we have remaining left
is to exec the remaining bills in terms
of getting together
um how many here would like to skip next
week and then reconvene in two weeks
okay
so that's what we'll do we'll reconvene
in two weeks uh to exec the remaining
bills
so other than that we're all finished
for today thank you everyone for uh your
efforts today you notice in the calendar
yes I was hoping you were going to ask
how many would like to meet in three
thank you for your help Mr chairman
today you did a wonderful you did a
it was it was I could hit either Tom say
don't let them do it
thank you
but Greg saved you
I think it's that he threw a Lifeline
soy I suspected